gebe ich jetzt ab Alexander Kähler ist
mit Gästen für Sie vor Ort
ja guten Morgen Tina Dauster liebe
Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer bevor es aber
hier zur Gas- und strompreisbremsen
Verabschiedung kommt ein wichtiges
Vorhaben das nahezu jeden bei uns
betrifft gibt es noch einen Festakt im
Bundestag für 30 Minuten so viel Zeit
will man sich nehmen es gibt nämlich
zwei Jubiläen zu feiern
vorgestern vor 50 Jahren am 13 dezember
1972 wurde zum ersten Mal in Deutschland
eine Frau als Bundestagspräsidentin
gewählt annemarie Renger von der SPD die
SPD hatte die Bundestagswahl 1972
gewonnen wurde zum ersten Mal stärkste
Fraktion und stellte die
Bundestagspräsidenten daraus zu
schließen dass die SPD auch damals schon
eine Hort der Frauen verstehen ist das
ist allerdings falsch
Annemarie Wenger hat später erzählt ich
habe mich in der Fraktion selbst für das
Amt des der Bundestagspräsidentin
vorgeschlagen glauben sie sonst die
hätten mich genommen
war 1972 weltweit auch die einzige Frau
die Präsidentin eines freigewählten
Parlaments war im Jahre 2008 ist sie
hoch verehrt hoch angesehen im Alter von
fast 89 Jahren verstorben der andere
Jubilar der ist heute anwesend am
gleichen Tag an dem Annemarie Renner zur
Bundestagspräsidentin gewählt worden ist
am 13 dezember 1972 damals ein erster
offizieller Arbeitstag als Abgeordneter
30 Jahre jung Wahlkreis Offenburg hört
auf den Namen Wolfgang Schäuble Wolfgang
Schäuble hat eine beispiellose
politische Karriere hingelegt mit Höhen
und Tiefen wie wir wissen er hat nahezu
alle politischen Spitzenämter bekleidet
mit Ausnahme das Amts des
Bundespräsidenten und des Bundeskanzlers
aber auch in diesen beiden Ämtern ist er
relativ knapp vorbeigeschrammt er ist
der dienstälteste Abgeordnete in der
Geschichte nationaler deutscher
Parlamente das gilt sowohl für den
Bundestag wie auch für den Reichstag
dafür wird er auch geehrt nachher ab 9
Uhr bis 9:30 Uhr und 9:30 Uhr kommt dann
das wichtigste Thema wo das heutigen
Tages die Verabschiedung der Strom und
gaspreisbremse und dazu zu diesem
politischen Teil gibt's jetzt auch das
Interview gesehen ist bei uns
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Fraktion die Linken und gleicher
Funktion bei der FDP Lutz Köhler
Entschuldigung Lukas Köhler Frau
das erste Gesetzesvorhaben mit dem alle
restlos zufrieden sind
aber können sie denn der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse etwas Positives
abgewinnen wir sind natürlich nicht
restlos zufrieden und wir werden auch
nicht zustimmen sondern uns enthalten
die größte Schwierigkeit oder das größte
Problem dieses Gesetzes ist ja das ist
sozial völlig unausgewogen ist es wird
erstattet nach verbraucht der Vorjahre
bzw ungedeckelt aber zum Beispiel jemand
der in einer kleinen Einzimmerwohnung
wohnt oder in einer kleinen Mietwohnung
und sowieso schon immer gespart hat die
muss man mal erklären wo er noch weiter
sparen soll und warum er nicht 100 %
Erstattung bekommt jemand der in einer
großen Villa wohnt vielleicht noch eine
Sauna hat und Swimmingpool den er
beheizt bekommt auch erstattet und das
ist total ungerecht zumindest ja aus
unserer Steuergeld kommt und im
kommenden Jahr wieder die Schuldenbremse
angezogen werden soll das heißt dann
dann wird überall im sozialen Bereich
gespart für uns ist das nicht innehmbar
Lukas Köhler wer viel Energie verbraucht
weil er sich das leisten kann der würde
auch besonders sehr stark entlastet das
auch gerade schon angedeutet gibt es da
eine soziale Schieflage in dem
Gesetzesvorhaben nein also ich glaube es
gibt keine soziale Schieflage per se wir
sehen ja das bei der gaspreisbremse eben
genau diese Frage schon geklärt wird
dadurch dass wir eben die Besteuerung
einführen und wir haben ja einen sehr
starken Steuersatz auch für diejenigen
die viel Geld verdienen und damit auch
viel Steuern zahlen genauso wird auch
der Steuersatz hier angewandt damit
glaube ich auch nicht dass es eine
soziale Schieflage gibt um aber
natürlich dafür zu sorgen dass die
Menschen entlastet werden dies besonders
hart getroffen haben dieses Jahr führen
wir neben den Bremsen auch noch die
härtefallfonds ein ähm in diversesten
Bandbreiten und versuchen da auch den
Menschen wirklich über das über die
Härten die durch diesen Krieg den Putin
gegen uns führt auf Energie Seite
wirklich auszugleichen die nächste Frage
ist möglicherweise für den heutigen
Berliner morgen mit -8 Grad etwas
unpassen aber es gibt ja auch wieder
wärmere Perioden im Winter ist der
subventionierte Anteil der Energie die
wir jetzt haben also 80%
Unternehmen generell zu hoch weil
einfach zu wenig Energie eingespart wird
am letzten Sonntag sind ein Prozent der
gesamten Energie der gasvorrät in
Deutschland verbraucht worden ich kann
nur noch mal bekräftigen dass es da eine
soziale Schieflage gibt gerade Menschen
die wenig Geld haben wohnen in schlecht
isolierten Häusern das heißt selbst wenn
sie die Heizung unter Null drehen würden
was ja gar nicht möglich ist können sie
nicht weiter sparen und ich muss auch
dem Argument widersprechen dass das
Steuersystem das alles aus regelt die
Steuer Mehreinnahmen die jetzt
eingeplant werden durch die Abschöpfung
von sogenannten übergewinnen die
gleichen mit nichten das aus was für die
Bremsen aus dem Steuer aus genau aber
ich will es noch mal deutlich sagen was
aus dem steuersäcke bezahlt wird und die
ist Steuergeld gehört ja allen sollte
allen zu Gute kommen und wird sehr
ungleich verteilt und die FDP hat sich
wieder sehr entschlossen durchgesetzt in
der Koalition ich kann sie nur wieder
als Vermögensverwalter der Reichen
bezeichnen gut ob das ist wenn wir jetzt
bei der nächsten Frage gleich sehen
Energie intensive Unternehmen den graust
ist ja vor der nächsten Zeit
einige oder viele rechnen sogar mit
einer Insolvenz sind die
unternehmenshilfen für die auch die FDP
der Ampel verantwortlich ist wirklich
zielgenau klar also ich glaube gerade
bei den Unternehmen sehen wir dass wir
viel tun und tun müssen weil wir müssen
natürlich auch für Arbeitsplätze sorgen
die Leute haben jetzt wirklich Sorge
gehabt lange Zeit davor wie geht es mit
der wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung weiter
wie sie wirklich die Inflation aber auch
diese Krise aus und wir sorgen mit den
Geldern die wir in die Hand nehmen
wirklich dafür dass kleine
mittelständische aber auch große
Unternehmen in Deutschland ihre
Arbeitsplätze erhalten dass sie dafür
sorgen dass sie auch wieder reden
investieren all das haben wir jetzt in
dieses Paket gepackt und ist auch gut
und richtig so und ich glaube wir sehen
auch natürlich mit diesem Instrument
dass wir in der Breite helfen klar ist
nicht alles gegen finanziert durch die
Steuereinnahmen über der
strompreisbremse das war auch nie das
Ziel in so einer Krise in einem Krieg
der gegen uns geführt wird müssen wir
auch als Staaten unterstützen deswegen
haben wir diese 200 Milliarden
aufgenommen und über den Wirtschaft
stabilisierungsform schütten wir das
Geld aus das hilft den Unternehmen das
hilft dabei diesen Standort zu erhalten
und es sorgt dafür dass die Menschen gut
über die Zeit kommen und das ist das was
der Ampel wichtig ist also wenn man bei
dem Unternehmensbereich noch Herr Kühler
Unternehmen die staatliche
Stützungsmaßnahmen bekommen die werden
bei der Auszahlung von Dividenden und
Boni entweder eingeschränkt oder es wird
ganz verboten da war die FDP aber nicht
dafür das war ihnen eigentlich nicht
recht dieser Kompromiss ist ja in
letzter im letzten Moment noch
geschlossen worden warum
kriegen Unternehmen die auch vom Staat
und versteuerzahler unterstützt werden
sollen auch noch Dividenden und wohne
bekommen jedenfalls die die Spitzen
Leute in diesem Unternehmen da muss ich
Ihnen widersprechen ganz klar weil die
Haushälter haben in ihrem
maßgabenschluss Beschluss zum
Wirtschaften Stabilisierung vor ja schon
vor einiger Zeit als quasi das Geld
aufgenommen wurde und meines Wissens
nach sind das alle Haushälter nämlich
auch die ampelhaushälter als auch unsere
schon dafür gesorgt dass klar gemacht
wurde das Boni und Dividenden
rausgenommen werden ab und Sie haben
richtig beschrieben ab zwei Hüllen
einmal 25 Millionen Euro wer mehr als 25
Millionen Euro Bremsen Unterstützung des
Staates bekommt der kann für seine
spitzen Leute keine Boni auszahlen knapp
50 Millionen Euro Unterstützung gibt es
keine Boni und Dividenden das waren
Kompromiss den bei uns die Haushälter
miteinander vereinbart haben und dem
hinter dem stehen wir ganz genauso wie
der Rest der Ampel ich muss da ein
bisschen korrigieren in der Tat wir
haben das ja gestern im
Haushaltsausschuss besprochen und
beschlossen es gibt zwei Stufen aber bei
den 25 Millionen ist es so dass die Boni
und Dividenden im Vergleich zum vorher
nicht erhöht werden dürfen also sie
dürfen weiterhin ausgezahlt werden das
heißt Unternehmen die mit
steuerzahlermitteln subventioniert
werden dürfen weiter ihre Spitzen Leute
hoch bezahlen und das ist natürlich auch
ungerecht und das merken ja die Leute
die erleben dass wir den größten real
lohnverlust seit Bestehen der
Bundesrepublik haben die Löhne steigen
zwar aber die Inflation ist viel viel
schneller und darum muss man genau auf
diese Fragen besonders schauen
tut mir leid aber also Dividenden
erstmal haben gar nichts mit den Spitzen
Geld zu tun sondern da geht es um die
Substanz der Unternehmen wenn wir jetzt
großflächig gesagt hätten und 50
Millionen ist viel das stimmt weil das
ja die Hilfen sind nicht das was das
Unternehmen einen sondern in den Hilfen
wenn wir das jetzt rausgenommen hätten
würden wir dafür sorgen dass es ein
Ausverkauf deutscher Firmen in
Deutschland gäbe und bei den Boni das
ist nun mal Teil ganz oft auch der
Gehälter übrigens nicht nur der
Spitzengehälter sondern von dem
mittleren Management den Leuten aus der
Mittelschicht in Deutschland die darüber
ihr Gehalt bestimmen und deswegen muss
man sehr sehr vorsichtig sein wenn man
daran geht klar ist auch wenn wir
wirklich große staatliche Summen in die
Hand nehmen dass wir dann da vorsichtig
sind und sagen na ja das kann jetzt
nicht aufgrund der staatlichen Mittel
noch mal erhöht werden bzw muss
ausgeschlossen werden ist klar aber man
muss da glaube ich sehr zielgerichtet
bleiben darf ich da mal noch ansetzen
ohne Dividenden sind bei den Linken
nicht sehr beliebt aber wir reden ja im
Moment ja nicht von
internationalen Großkonzernen wo die
Spitzenmanager auf ihre Millionen
Gehälter noch oben was drauf kriegen
sondern ist war ja zu hören dass zum
Beispiel in den Familienunternehmen die
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmer ein
Großteil ihres Einkommens über solche
Dividenden beziehen was machen wir in
dem Fall wenn gleichzeitig die
Unternehmen weil sie in wirtschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten geraten
dann auch diese Dividenden ja eigentlich
bezahlen müssten müssen dann die
Familienunternehmer auf Gehalt
verzichtenden Zeit lang also ich finde
den Begriff Familienunternehmen die muss
man sich mal genauer anschauen
normalerweise denkt man ja so im
umgangssprachlichen Gebrauch das ist der
Bäckermeister an der Ecke oder eine
kleine Schneiderei oder ein Friseursalon
aber unter dem Oberbegriff
Familienunternehmen verstecken sich ja
in Deutschland solche Familien wie
Quandt und Klatten die also BMW führen
und andere und da wäre mir an einer
Differenzierung sehr gelesen aber das
war glaube ich nicht gemeint sondern in
der Tat eher der erste Fall den sie
genannt haben aber dafür werden sie für
Differenzierung natürlich bin ich für
die Differenzierung und natürlich ist es
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt Arbeitsplätze
zu erhalten und in dem Gesetz ist mir
auch viel zu wenig an
Arbeitsplatzsicherheit geregelt es wird
gesagt Unternehmen die
Unterstützung erhalten vom Staat müssen
bis 2024 90% der Arbeitsplätze erhalten
aber was ist denn nach 20 24 und wir
haben ja wirklich böse Erfahrung mit dem
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds in der
corona-krise Stichwort Lufthansa da
wurde das Geld
geschmissen wieder zurückgezahlt das ist
richtig aber ganz ganz viele
Arbeitsplätze sind verloren gegangen und
das darf natürlich in dieser Situation
überhaupt nicht der Fall sein ich will
aber noch hatte Stichwort Krieg
aufgreifen weil das Herr Köhler ja
mehrfach in den Mund genommen hat wir
müssen doch alles tun um
wirtschaftskriege zu beenden oder zu
vermeiden wir sind im Augenblick in
einer Lage dass wir in der
Auseinandersetzung sind mit Russland wir
sind in der Auseinandersetzung mit China
mit den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
und da brauchen wir eine langfristige
Konzeption und ich sehe bei der Ampel im
Augenblick nur
kurzfristig und die USA miteinander
vergleichen ist völlig absur tut mir
leid dass ich demnächst geht
einfach nicht
widersprechensverbrecher wie Putin
anknicken um Gottes Willen auf keinen
Fall wir müssen doch aus der Geschichte
lernen wir hatten eine einseitige
Abhängigkeit von Russland von der CDU
und von der SPD damals organisiert über
die vielen Jahre der großen Koalition
und jetzt müssen wir uns davon bewahren
in eine nächste einseitige Abhängigkeit
anzukommen zum Beispiel habe ich war in
Katar hat sich dort verneigt vor den
Scheichs also wir können doch nicht von
den einen Oligarchen zu den anderen
olligarchen wechseln sondern wir
brauchen vielfältige
wirtschaftsbeziehung in alle Richtungen
in viele Richtung und wir dürfen uns
nicht von einem abhängig machen ich
würde gerne zur Gaspreise zurückkehren
Köhler es geht um die Wirksamkeit des
Gesetzes wie können sie denn verhindern
dass die Energieerzeuger das ja gerade
schon angesprochen worden angesichts der
doch starkes staatlichen Subventionen
bei den Tarifen jetzt noch eine Schippe
drauflegen nach dem Motto der Zahl der
Stadt zahlt ja ihn gibt drei Stellen wo
wir explizit Missbrauch ausschließen ist
eines wir frieren den Grundbetrag
sozusagen ein ab auf den September
diesen Jahres wo noch nicht klar war
welche Art von von Hilfen und Bremsen
kommen und das glaube ich auch richtig
dafür dass wir dass wir dafür sorgen
dass nur noch in Notfällen oder nur noch
wenn es wirklich begründete Ausnahmen
gibt dieser Grundtarif angepasst werden
kann das ist sozusagen verhindert diese
Frage von ihm zum zweiten haben wir
natürlich einen eigenen Paragraph noch
mal geschaffen um missbräuchlichkeiten
missbräuchliche
Rüstung dieser Bremsen zu verändern zu
verhindern auch über das Kartellamt dass
das überprüft und der dritte Schritt ist
dass wir der mit der gemeinsamen als
Bundestag und Bundesregierung dafür
sorgen können über eine Verordnung dass
wir an anderen Stellen noch mal anpassen
wenn wir merken dass es
missbräuchlichkeiten gibt klar ist auch
das ist ein ganz neues Instrument klar
ist auch das ist jetzt gerade in dieser
Situation neu geschaffen und man kann
nicht ein perfektes Gesetz machen und
alle Fehler schon ausgeräumt haben
deswegen müssen wir schnell reagieren
können dafür haben wir gesorgt wir
müssen aber auf jeden Fall ein einfaches
schnelles und wirksames Instrument
schaffen das haben wir mit dieser Gas
und der Strompreis Bremse jetzt
vorgelegt und dafür damit können wir
dafür sorgen dass die Härten wirklich
ausgeglichen werden und im Zweifel nach
Steuern können zu den Härten ist ein
Punkt der völlig fehlt das ist das
Verbot von Strom und gasperren und das
vor haben wir als LINKE immer wieder
gefordert das hätte in diesem Gesetz
stehen müssen das heißt also das hat ja
auch damit zu tun das ist auch ein
Moderatorin glaube ich für Mieten geben
sollen wir seine Miete nicht mehr
bezahlt hat oder bezahlen kann im im
Winter das er dann auch entsprechend
vorher nicht gekündigt werden kann wird
sich da die Ampel noch bewegen wir haben
mit der mit den aktuellen Hilfen das
sind ja nicht nur diese 200 Milliarden
sondern die 96 Milliarden die wir dieses
Jahr schon ausgeschüttet haben wo viel
Geld jetzt bei den Menschen angekommen
ist dafür gesorgt dass wir die Härten
dieses Krieges auseinander
aufhalten dass wir dafür sorgen dass die
Menschen unterstützt sind dass Sie gut
durch den Winter kommen und die
Diskussion zu mieten Moratorien oder dem
schweren von Gas und strompreisbremsen
ist eine lang geführte aber hat mit
diesem Thema jetzt erstmal selber nichts
zu tun weil wir jetzt den Menschen
wirklich helfen können für die
Betroffenen ist es aber sehr wichtig
meine Position ist kann sie nur noch mal
wiederholen Strom und Gaspreis werden
müssen verboten werden wir können noch
lange darüber reden geht aber nicht mehr
das klingt zeigen heißt ab ins Parlament
es geht gleich los mit dem Festakt und
danach mit dem Thema deswegen ich
gesprochen hat mit Gesine Lötzsch und
mit Lukas Köhler vielen Dank dass sie da
waren so liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer
ich habe es vorhin schon gesagt als
erstes kommt jetzt dieser 30 Minuten
Festakt zu Ehren von annemarie Renger
und Wolfgang Schäuble 50 Jahre die erste
Bundestagspräsidentin an Amerika und
seit 50 Jahren ununterbrochen Wolfgang
Schäuble Abgeordneter im Deutschen
Bundestag wir blicken schon ins
Parlament in den Plenarsaal
8 9 Uhr bis 9 Uhr wird es dann wie
gesagt
zu diesem testakt kommen danach zwei
namentliche Abstimmungen zur Gas und zur
strompreisbremse dieser Gong der jetzt
ertönt bedeutet dass die
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Basis die
zweite in der Geschichte des Bundestages
von der SPD und unmittelbare Vorgängerin
und unmittelbare Nachfolgerinnen
Entschuldigung von Wolfgang Schäuble
jetzt den Saal betritt hier kommt sie
sie für die Laudatio diesen Festakt
jetzt leiten und lautet sie auf beide
halten und wir geben hinein ins
Parlament
meine Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ich wünsche Ihnen allen
einen schönen guten Morgen die Sitzung
ist eröffnet
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich begrüße auch heute morgen auf der
Ehrentribüne
die frühere Präsidentin der freien
Volkskammer der DDR Frau Dr Bergmann
Pohl
sowie den früheren Bundestagspräsidenten
dr wolfgang Thierse
begrüße auch sehr herzlich Frau Schäuble
und Familie und weitere Weggefährten auf
der Ehrentribüne herzlich willkommen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der 13
dezember
1972 ist ein besonderes Datum in unserer
Geschichte an diesem Tag hat der
Deutsche Bundestag zum ersten Mal eine
Frau zur Präsidentin gewählt die Zeitung
das Parlament Titel damals
der zweite Mann im Staat eine Frau
nicht nur im geteilten Deutschland war
dies eine Premiere
annemarie Renger war weltweit die erste
Frau an der Spitze eines frei gewählten
Parlaments
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Wahlbeteiligung lag 1972 bei traumhaften
91,1 Prozent
der Frauenanteil im Parlament allerdings
war so niedrig wie jemals zuvor und
übrigens auch danach zu Beginn der
siebten Wahlperiode gehörten nur 30
Frauen den Bundestag an
5,8% der Abgeordneten
in ihrer Antrittsrede sagte annemarie
Renger die Wahl einer Frau für das Amt
hat verständlicherweise einiges Aufsehen
erregt
das erstmalige und mit hin ungewohnte
Gerät in die Gefahr zum einmaligen und
besonderen erhoben zu werden Zitat Ende
in der Tat dauerte es zwölf Jahre bis
Rita Süßmuth
eine Frau wiederum an der Spitze des
Bundestages war und nach Rita süßmut
dauerte es sogar 23 Jahre bis zur
dritten Bundestagspräsidentin heute
nehmen Frauen selbstverständlich ihren
Platz in der Politik und in der
Gesellschaft ein und das verdanken wir
auch der parlamentarischen Pionierarbeit
von annemarie Renger
sie ebnete Frauen den Weg in die Politik
und in der Politik annemarie Renger
nutzte ihre Stellung als
Bundestagspräsidentin um wie sie selbst
sagte der Sache der Frauen zu dienen sie
wusste politisches Engagement und
Familienleben lassen sich nur
vereinbaren wenn die Rahmenbedingungen
passen das gilt auch heute und nicht nur
im Parlament für annemarie Renger
gehörte dazu den Frauen der
Bundestagsverwaltung die Vereinbarkeit
von Familie und Beruf zu ermöglichen die
Eröffnung der bundestagskita im Jahr
1970 geht auch auf ihre Initiative
zurück
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Frauenanteil ist mit knapp 35 Prozent
auch im aktuellen 20 Bundestag zu
niedrig
Frauen sind auch heute in
Führungspositionen unterrepräsentiert
sie verdienen oft weniger sie leisten
mehrheitlich die kehrarbeit mit allen
Folgen der Weg zur echten Gleichstellung
ist noch weit annemarie Renger kann uns
aber mit ihrer Beharrlichkeit Vorbild
sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen annemarie
Renger wurde 1919 geboren im Jahr der
Einführung des Frauenwahlrechts ihr
sozialdemokratisches Elternhaus stand in
Opposition zum Nationalsozialismus nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg wurde Kurt
Schumacher ihr politischer Mentor und
vertrauter
37 Jahre gehörte sie dem Deutschen
Bundestag ununterbrochen an sie war die
erste parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin
der SPD-Fraktion vier Jahre
Bundestagspräsidentin und 14 Jahre
vizepräsidentin
ihr half dabei dass sie eine gehörige
Portion Selbstbewusstsein besaß wie sie
sagte als Abgeordnete behielt sie immer
ihren eigenen Kopf nicht immer zur
Freude ihrer Fraktion
den Deutschen Bundestag führte sie
souverän mit natürlicher Autorität und
mit Charme Annemarie Ringer hat nicht
nur bewiesen dass Frauen es können sie
prägte die damalige Politik in vielen
Fragen sie führte Bürgergespräche im
ganzen Land sie trieb die
parlamentsreform voran sie etablierte
den wissenschaftlichen Dienst des
Deutschen Bundestages sie stärkte das
petitionswesen und intensivierte die
Arbeit der onkettkommission ihre
Herzensangelegenheit war die Aussöhnung
mit Polen und Israel 14 Jahre lang
leitete sie die deutsch-israelische
Parlamentariergruppe
der glücklichste Augenblick ihres
politischen Lebens war aber für sie der
9 November
1989 als die Nachricht vom Fall der
Mauer sich verbreitete leitete sie
gerade als Vizepräsidentin die Beratung
im Bundestag in Bonn
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen annemarie
Renger war als Bundestagspräsidentin
auch deshalb so erfolgreich weil sie
einen feinen Humor besaß in ihrer
Antrittsrede würdigte sie die jungen
Abgeordneten mit folgenden Worten ich
zitiere in unserer Mitte begrüße ich die
neuen Mitglieder dieses Hauses die mit
ihrer großen Anzahl jüngerer
Abgeordneten zum ersten Mal des
Durchschnittsalter des Bundestages unter
die 50 Jahresgrenze gedrückt haben Zitat
Ende
und damit begrüßte annemarie Renger auch
sie lieber Kollege Schäuble sie waren
gerade 30 Jahre alt ein promovierter
Jurist und Finanzbeamter
wenn ich auf ihr Lebenswerk Blicke kann
ich eins kaum glauben nach eigener
Auskunft waren sie eigentlich ein
verlegenheitskandidat der CDU in ihrem
Wahlkreis
seit einem halben Jahrhundert gehören
sie nun ununterbrochen im Deutschen
Bundestag an das ist einmalig in der
gesamten Geschichte des deutschen
Parlamentarismus das ist eine Ära
sie haben sogar august-bebel übertroffen
der nur 44 Jahre reist das Abgeordneter
war
lieber Herr Schäuble ihre Wählerinnen
und Wähler haben Sie 14 Mal in Folge mit
einem Direktmandat betraut und ihnen
damit das Vertrauen geschenkt das
wichtigste Kapital in einer
parlamentarischen Demokratie sie haben
die Geschicke unseres Landes in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten wie nur wenige
geprägt als Kanzleramtsminister haben
sie maßgeblich die deutsch-deutschen
Beziehungen gestaltet als Innenminister
unter Helmut Kohl haben sie den
Einigungsvertrag entworfen und den
wiedervereinigungsprozess entscheidend
mit gelenkt sie sind zum Architekten der
deutschen Einheit geworden als
Innenminister unter Angela Merkel haben
Sie zum Beispiel die Islamkonferenz ins
Leben gerufen ein Meilenstein in der
Integrationspolitik
als Finanzminister haben sie Deutschland
und Europa durch die Finanzen Euro-Krise
navigiert Kristin Lagarde nannte sie
einmal einen Felsen ein Giganten
als Bundestagspräsident haben Sie
beispielsweise die deutsch-französische
Parlamentarische Versammlung etabliert
und mit dem Bürgerrat ein neues
Instrument zur Belebung unserer
Demokratie auf den Weg gebracht
für mich sind sie ganz besonders ein
großer Europäer der sich mit
Leidenschaft und aus tiefster
Überzeugung für die Einheit Europas
einsetzt dieses Engagement wurde
übrigens auch im Jahr 2012 mit dem
Karlspreis gewürdigt
Angela Merkel hat ihre politischen
Verdienste einmal so zusammengefasst
Wolfgang Schäuble ist ein Glücksfall für
die deutsche und europäische Politik
wie annemarie Renger haben sie sich
immer mit unglaublicher Disziplin und
großen Pflicht und
Verantwortungsbewusstsein in den Dienst
unseres Staates gestellt und mit Freude
an der Politik in einer Festschrift
wurden sie einmal als fröhlicher
Sisyphus betitelt ich denke mit dieser
Beschreibung können Sie ganz gut leben
lieber Herr Schäuble nicht ohne Grund
gelten sie als ein Mann der Exekutive
ihre Gestaltungskraft und ihr
Gestaltungsdrang sind berühmt ich habe
jetzt einige Wegmarken ihres Wirkens
erwähnt zugleich sind sie aber bis heute
Parlamentarier aus Leidenschaft
sie kennen den Bundestag aus
verschiedenen Perspektiven als einfacher
Abgeordneter parlamentarischer
Geschäftsführer Fraktionschef
Oppositionsführer Alterspräsident und
Bundestagspräsident und in jeder dieser
Position waren sie ein großer Verfechter
des demokratischen Streits im Respekt
vor dem Gegenüber als
Fraktionsvorsitzender waren sie einen
gefürchteter debattenredner ihr Wort hat
Gewicht und Überzeugungskraft ihre
mitreißende Rede in der
berlin-bondebatte am 20 Juni 1991 ist
dafür ein starkes Beispiel
ihre plenarrede war eine der
entscheidenden reden die am Ende zum
Beschluss für Berlin als Parlaments und
Regierungssitz führte und ihnen ganz
nebenbei auch die Ehrenbürgerschaft der
Hauptstadt einbrachte
[Gelächter]
Streit ist das Salz der Demokratie das
war immer ihre Devise zum konstruktiven
Streit haben sie uns Abgeordnete als
Parlamentspräsident auch immer ermuntert
auch in herausfordernden Zeiten sie
haben das Parlament immer angehalten
gegensätzliche Standpunkte auch
auszuhalten den politischen Streit haben
sie nie als Selbstzweck verstanden
sondern als ein Instrument und
widerstreitende Interessen in Rede und
Gegenrede zu artikulieren und bei
drängenden Zukunftsfragen auch wirklich
voranzukommen
über den Bundestag haben sie gesagt ich
zitiere hier ist der Ort an dem wir
streiten dürfen an dem wir streiten
sollen fair und nach Regeln
leidenschaftlich aber auch mit der
Gelassenheit die einer erregten
Öffentlichkeit Beispiel geben könnte
Zitat Ende
lieber Herr Schäuble auch nach 50 Jahren
dienen sie den Parlament mit ihrer
unvergleichlichen Erfahrung mit ihrer
Weitsicht und ihrem intellektuellen
Scharfsinn wir sind jetzt gespannt auf
ihre Ausführung Herr Schäuble sie haben
das Wort
so wird sich also der Jubilar jetzt noch
mal selbst zu Wort melden im Parlament
dem er seit 50 Jahren angehört ein
allzeitrekord keiner ist auch nur
annähernd an diese Zeit gekommen in der
Geschichte nationaler deutscher
Parlamente sei es der Reichstag oder der
Bundestag und jetzt Wolfgang Schäuble
frau Präsidentin
Kollegen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
ich bedanke mich sehr für ihre
sehre
mich ehrende
Würdigung
und auch für die
für Ihr Angebot hier
einiges einige Worte sagen zu dürfen
annemarie Renger
war eine
allzeit respektierte
Bundestagspräsidentin sie haben sie
zu Recht eben gewürdigt
annemarie Renger achtete streng auf die
Würde des Hauses
so wie man sie damals verstanden als
einmal als sozialdemokratischer Kollege
ohne Krawatte im Plenum saß
[Gelächter]
da ließ sie ihm durch ein
parlamentsassistenten unauffällig einen
Winter bringen und der hatte noch
widerspruchslos angelegt
ich kann mich übrigens nicht erinnern
dass die Tatsache dass eine Frau das Amt
inne hatte mir besonders bemerkenswert
erschienen wäre
vielleicht war manches vor 50 Jahren
doch schon selbstverständlicher als
heute viele glauben
gewöhnungsbedürftig für uns in der Union
war allerdings das erstmal seine
Sozialdemokratin das Amt aus
aber das ist ja heute auch keine
Besonderheit mehr
übrigens hatte 1972 der erste Bericht
des Klapper from
zu den Grenzen des Wachstums schon die
Gefahren von exponentiell wachsenden
Ressourcen für Ressourcenverbrauch und
Umweltbelastung aufgezeigt er hat auch
viel Aufmerksamkeit erfahren auch bei
mir
aber er hat leider zu wenig praktische
Schlussfolgerung gefunden
auch deswegen verstehe ich warum die
junge Generation heute so drängt
und ich sehe die Herausforderung für die
parlamentarische Demokratie zu erklären
warum in der freiheitlichen Gesellschaft
Prozesse oft langsam verlaufen
1973 folgte übrigens schon die erste
Energiekrise
weil damals die
Objekt die Arab die von den Objekt die
war damals von den arabischen Staaten
dominiert die wollten mit einer
Verknappung der Ölförderung den Westen
zu einer weniger Israel freundlichem
Politik zwingen wir hatten in der
Adventszeit
1973 Fahrverbote wir sind auf der
Autobahn Fahrrad gefahren und und uns
spazieren gegangen
der einspar beim Ölverbrauch war
übrigens auch damals gering
meine Partei meine Partei hatte im
Wahlkampf 1972
sie haben eben noch die Wahlbeteiligung
zu Recht erwähnt vor allem die
anzeigende Inflation mit ihren Gefahren
für Wachstum und Beschäftigung
thematisiert
und irgendwie hatten wir im Beifall
unsere Anhängerin Wahlkampf gar nicht
richtig mitbekommen dass manche Reformen
das soziale Liberalen Koalition 69 bis
72 in einer Gesellschaft die sich in der
Nachkriegszeit zunächst vor allem auf
das Wirtschaftswunder er konzentriert
hat und Zustimmung fanden
und vor allem hatten wir nicht
verstanden dass die Fortschreibung der
Westintegration mit der neuen Ost und
Deutschlandpolitik der begrenzten
Zusammenarbeit unter der Überschrift
Wandel durch Annäherung nicht nur mit
dem Friedensnobelpreis für Willy Brandt
sondern auch mit wachsender Zustimmung
in der öffentlichen Meinung moderiert
wurde man sieht
auch wenn heute alles ganz anders zu
sein scheint als vor 50 Jahren so ist
doch auch nicht alles ganz neu
nach meinen Erfahrungen bin ich mir
übrigens auch nicht so sicher
dass aus Anfang
idealistischem Protest mit einer anfängt
zu strafbaren Mittel zu greifen liegt
auch schlimme Entscheidungen und
Entwicklungen entstehen können und
deswegen ist es gut wenn unsere
zuständigen Behörden hier auch hier den
Anfängen wehren
auch wenn sich
auch wenn sich die Geschichte nicht
wiederholt lassen sich aus der
distanzierten Betrachtung von
Entwicklungen ja Entscheidungshilfen für
Gegenwart und Zukunft gewinnen die
Bereitschaft zur zusammenarbeiten und
Partnerschaft darf nicht zum verzichter
verteidigungsabschreckungsfähigkeit
Führen das haben wir nach Putins
Überfall auf die Ukraine wieder lernen
müssen es stand so schon im
h-mail-bericht der NATO von 1967 und wir
hatten dann die gesellschaftliche
Debatte Ende der 70er Anfang der 80er
Jahre nachdem Helmut Schmidt 79 in der
NATO den sogenannten doppelbeschluss
durchgesetzt hatte der wollte eine Lücke
in der Glaubwürdigkeit der abstreckung
schließen weil die Sowjetunion mit
Raketen mittlerer Reichweite die nur
Europa aber nicht Amerika erreichen
konnten ein Bedrohungspotenzial
geschaffen hatte
von Themen Helmut Schmidt und dann auch
die NATO überzeugt waren dass es
entweder beseitigt werden oder durch
eine entsprechende Aufstellung von
Waffensystemen mit mittlerer Reichweite
in Europa ausgeglichen werden müssen an
diesem doppelbeschluss hat Helmut
Schmidt die Unterstützung seiner Partei
verloren der Widerstand richtet sich
sich bemerkenswerterweise nicht gegen
die auf uns gerichteten sowjetischen
Raketen sondern gegen die zu unserem
Schutz notfalls zu treffenden Maßnahmen
meines Erachtens gehört zu den großen
Leistungen von Bundeskanzler Kohl nach
dem Regierungswechsel 82
dass er diesen NATO-Doppelbeschluss
gegen heftigen öffentlichen Widerstand
vollzogen hat vielleicht wäre die
Geschichte
vielleicht wäre die Geschichte mit
Michael Gorbatschow ohne diese
Entscheidung anders verlaufen jedenfalls
hat uns Putin jetzt gezeigt dass wir
auch im 21 Jahrhundert in Frieden nur
sichern können wenn wir auch in der Lage
sind uns gegebenenfalls zu verteidigen
wir hätten es wissen können wir wollten
es nicht sehen sagte die frühere
Verteidigungsministerin Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer
das ist Bedrohungen durch terroristische
asymmetrische Kriegsführung auch nichts
staatlicher Akteure gibt haben wir am 11
September 2001 mit den Anschlägen auf
das World Trade Center erfahren die
Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wurde danach vom Peter
Struck zu zitieren am hindukus
verteidigt wir haben bis heute keine
gute Antwort gefunden wie wir auf solche
Bedrohungen reagieren sollen in
Afghanistan nicht und jetzt in Mali auch
wieder nicht
der Sieg der freiheitlich
rechtsstaatlichen Demokratie den Francis
Fukuyama nach 1990 in seinem Ende der
Geschichte verkündete den HCM Huntington
schon in seinem class of zivilizations
96 hinterfragt und noch immer suchen wir
nach dem richtigen Maß an Respekt vor
unterschiedlichen Kulturen
Traditionen und Wertvorstellungen
einerseits und unserer universalen
Verantwortung für Menschenrechte
andererseits jedenfalls haben wir im
Vergleich zu 1972 als für uns in Europa
die Polarität des ostwestkonfliktes
alles andere zu überlagern schien die
größere Vielfalt und zugleich die
größere Vernetzung globaler Strukturen
lernen müssen
und wir sehen im übrigen dass wir uns in
Deutschland und in Europa sehr
anstrengen müssen wenn wir unsere
eigenen Ansprüchen im globalen Ranking
auch nur einigermaßen gerecht werden
wollen vielleicht
müssen wir Deutsche auch aufpassen dass
wir nicht als Besserwisser die ihren
eigenen Ansprüchen selbst nicht gerecht
werden international zu viel Sympathie
verlieren
dafür könnt ihr übrigens auch unsere
doch eher unbefriedigende Auftrieb bei
der Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Katar
manchen Beleg leben
verändert hat sich jedenfalls die
öffentliche Kommunikation die sich aus
den Print- und elektronischen Medien
viel stärker in sozialen Netzwerken
verlagert hat mit all den Gefahren für
die Stabilität unserer freiheitlichen
demokratischen grundwehrordnung die wir
ja fast überall in der Welt wo ich
solche Demokratien überhaupt gibt
beobachten müssen das Vertrauen in die
Fähigkeit von Politik Probleme zu lösen
sozialen Zusammenhalt zu gewähren einen
verlässlichen Rahmen und ausgewogenen
Rahmen für Freiheit und Sicherheit zu
gewährleisten das nimmt offenbar ab je
mehr wir uns bemühen jedes einzelne
Problem noch besser noch perfekter zu
lösen ich weiß nicht wie viele
entbürokratisierungskommission und
Initiativen wir in diesen 50 Jahren
hatten besser geworden ist jedenfalls
nichts
Föderalismus Kommission hatten wir zwei
ganz groß angelegte zwischen Bundestag
und Bundesrat und Bundesregierung
aber niemand behauptet ernsthaft dass
die föderale Ordnung unseres Landes die
ja im Grunde
weitgehend unbestritten ist mit
bundländern und kommunaler
Selbstverwaltung derzeit in guter
Verfassung sein
ich will mit ungebetenen Ratschlägen
wirklich zurückhaltend in meiner
alters-rolle vorgenommen deshalb will
ich ihr freundliches Angebot frau
Präsidentin heute einige Worte was in
diesen 50 Jahren sich wie die
Entwicklung war ich will das nicht
missbrauchen aber vielleicht ein Gedanke
wie wäre es
wie wäre es wenn wir eine breite
öffentliche Debatte anstoßen würden wie
wir unseren durch
perfektionistische Überregulierung
ähnlich dem gefesselten riesen Gulliver
in zu vielen fast schon handlungsunfähig
gewordenen Staat durch eine grundlegende
Neuordnung der Aufgaben auch zwischen
Staat und Gesellschaft und der
Neuordnung der Zuständigkeiten
einschließlich der Zuordnung von selbst
zu bestimmenden Einnahmen von Bund
Ländern und Kommunen wieder effizienter
machen könnten
die
Nationale Akademie der Wissenschaften
Leopoldina und die Berlin
brandenburgische Akademie der
Wissenschaft haben vor kurzem ein
interessanten Anstoß gegeben den könnten
wir aufgreifen und dann könnten wir auf
diesem Weg einer wieder als
handlungsfähig wahrgenommenen Politik
auch das Verständnis der Bürger fördern
das Demokratie eben wie kürzlich ein
Autor geschrieben hat eine Zumutung ist
und nicht ein Supermarkt für
Schnäppchenjäger das ist neben Rechte
auch Pflichten gibt und dass jeder nach
seiner ganz eigenen unterschiedlichen
Entscheidung auch seinen Beitrag für
andere und damit wird das Gemeinwohl
leisten kann leisten muss
wir sollten
auch wir sollten auch gerade in dem
jetzt so oft beschriebenen Wettbewerb
der Systeme bedenken
das bei all unseren Schwächen die
Grundwerte unserer freiheitlich
rechtsstaatlich und Ordnung sich fast
überall da auf der Welt wo diese Werte
nicht verwirklicht sind so großer
Anziehungskraft erfreuen dass die
Unterdrückten sich danach sehnen ihr
Leben riskieren um es vielleicht sich zu
erkämpfen und dass die Diktatoren genau
diese Anziehungskraft fürchten also
tragen wir Verantwortung zu zeigen dass
diese Werte auch funktionieren dass das
besser geht und weil wir so lange es uns
gut zu gehen scheint und schwer tun für
notwendige Änderungen ohne zu viel
Perfektionismus politische Mehrheiten zu
finden bleibe ich auch in der
gegenwärtigen Krise zuversichtlich denn
je mehr wir begreifen dass wir nicht
einfach so weitermachen dürfen
umso eher wächst die Chance für
notwendige Änderungen stabile Mehrheiten
zustande zu bringen das ist ja die Lehre
von Karl Poppers offener Gesellschaft
die im Prozess von 300 error doch immer
wieder den Weg zu neuen Lösungen findet
deshalb sind Krisen immer auch Chancen
und so
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren haben wir Grund zur
Zuversicht und das gilt heute genauso
wie vor 50 Jahren ich danke Ihnen
Standing Ovations für
Wolfgang Schäuble man muss mit oder
sollte mit historischen Begriffen
vorsichtig sein aber der Bundestag hat
er wirklich einen lebendes Denkmal in
seinen reine wird ja solange ist er
gewählt den Parlament noch bis zum
voraussichtlichen Ende der
Legislaturperiode Ende 2025 erhalten
bleiben wie gesagt Wolfgang Schäuble in
einer Erweiterung seiner Ehrung als
Abgeordneter 50 Jahre Mitglied des
Bundestags noch mal ein allzeit Rekord
kein anderer keine andere hat diesen
Rekord erreicht in der Geschichte
nationaler deutscher Parlamente wieder
im Reichstag noch hier im Bundestag
Wolfgang Schäuble
ja und jetzt schließt sich auch noch
eine gratulationskur an die man sonst
eigentlich nur nach der Wahl der
Bundeskanzlerin oder des Bundeskanzlers
kennen das aus allen Fraktionen auch aus
der AFD hier kommt das Weite und Tino
Palace Bild und auch von anderen
Fraktionen natürlich auch
Gratulanten da sind um Wolfgang Schäuble
für 50 Jahre Mitgliedschaft im Bundestag
zu gratulieren vergessen weil wir nicht
das auch die erste Bundestagspräsidentin
annemarie Renger von der SPD heute
geehrt worden ist vorgestern vor 50
Jahren wurde erstmal eine Frau in dieses
Amt gewählt von den 40 von
Entschuldigung von den 14
Bundestagspräsidenten waren allerdings
in der Parlamentsgeschichte des
Bundestages nur drei Frauen das war nach
annemarie Renger noch Rita süßmut von
1988 bis 1998 und jetzt seit dem
vergangenen Herbst stapelbars die dieser
Sitzung hier auch vorsteht elf Männer
drei Frauen da ist auch im Amt des
bundestagespräsidenten und der
Bundestagspräsidentin noch Luft nach
oben
Herr Dr Schäuble ich wusste es lohnt
sich immer ihnen Redezeit einzuräumen
und sie haben sich auch an die
Zeitkontingente gehalten auf das
haben Sie ja selbst als Präsident hier
oben auch immer eingehalten herzlichen
Dank dafür und ich gratuliere Ihnen sie
haben das ja gemerkt im Namen des ganzen
Hauses noch mal ganz ganz herzlich zu
ihrem 50-Jährigen parlamentsjubiläum
[Applaus]
und wie das Leben so spielt steigen wir
jetzt in die Tagesordnung ein da
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
heute bei den ohne Debatten Punkten noch
die sammelübersichten zu Petitionen auf
den Drucksachen
4.925 bis
4.939 aufzurufen
am Freitag ist nach interfraktioneller
Vereinbarung vorgesehen zu Beginn der
Tagesordnung in zweiter und dritter
Lesung den Entwurf eines Gesetzes für
einen besonderen Schutz
hinweisgebender Person sowie zu
Umsetzung der Richtlinie zum Schutz von
Personen die Verstöße gegen das
Unionsrecht melden mit einer
debattendauer von 39 Minuten zu beraten
die weiteren Tagesordnungspunkte der
koalitionsfraktion Rücken entsprechend
nach hinten
wobei Tagesordnungspunkt 24 nun mehr mit
einer debattendauer von 39 Minuten
beraten werden soll ich gehe davon aus
sie sind damit einverstanden ich sehe
keinen Widerspruch dann ist das so
beschlossen
ich rufe nun auf die Tagesordnungspunkte
8a und 8b jeweils zweite und dritte
Beratung der von den Fraktionen SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwürfe zur
Einführung von Preis Bremsen für
leitungsgebundenes Erdgas und Wärme und
Veränderung sonstiger Vorschriften sowie
zur Einführung einer strompreisbremse
und zu Änderungen weiterer
energierrechtlicher Bestimmungen der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
hat in seiner Beschlussempfehlung auch
Änderungen des fünften Buches
Sozialgesetzbuch des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes des
apothekengesetzes der Apotheken
Betriebsordnung und des stabilisierungs-
zu beiden Gesetzentwürfen erfolgt die
Schlussabstimmung jeweils namentlich für
die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 68
Minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
Aussprache und das Wort hat zu Beginn
für die Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Ricarda Land die katalang ist nicht nur
hier Mitglied im Bundestag sondern ja
auch kooper teilvorsitzende genannt
gemeinsam mit
noripurparteivorsitzende der
Bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen am 24 Februar
diesen Jahres begannt Vladimir Putin
seinen unmenschlichen Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine und von Beginn an nutzt er
nicht nur militärische Mittel sondern
auch Energiepreise als eine Waffe mit
dem klaren Ziel unseres Solidarität mit
der Ukraine zu brechen und uns zu
spalten doch das Problem begann vor dem
24 Februar denn warum waren wir so
angreifbar weil wir uns über Jahrzehnte
hinweg abhängig gemacht haben von
russischen Gas das vermeintlich billig
war heute können und müssen wir ganz
klar sagen russisches Gas war niemals
billig den Preis zahlen heute Millionen
von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
und in Zahlen vor allem diejenigen die
schon davor nicht wussten wie es ihm die
Runden kommen die jeden Euro zweimal
umdrehen mussten in Zahlen aber auch
Familien aus dem Mittelschicht und
kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen die gerade überlegen wie sie
eigentlich im nächsten Jahr noch
investieren können und an alle die haben
wir heute eine ganz klare Message wir
nehmen gelten die Hand übernehmen
Verantwortung und wir lassen niemand in
diese Krise alleine denn mit den Strom
und gaspreisbremsen da entlasten wir
Millionen von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
ganz konkret auf der Rechnung da
unterstützen wir Unternehmen in diesem
Land und schützen so den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland und das
sorgen wir mit den Härtefallregelungen
dafür dass das erhalten bleibt was wir
alle brauchen Krankenhäuser
Pflegeeinrichtungen wir schützen die
soziale Infrastruktur in diesem Land
und einen Teil von dem finanzieren wir
aus den sogenannten übergewinnen aus dem
zufallsgewinnen aus den Geldern die
einige wenige Energiekonzerne in diesen
Krieg gemacht haben und für mich ist das
ehrlich gesagt ein Gebot der
Gerechtigkeit denn wenn viele Menschen
Unternehmen Familien nicht mehr wissen
wie sie um die Runden kommen soll und
gleichzeitig einige wenige große Gewinne
machen dann ist es doch klar dass wir
ein Teil dieses Geldes nutzen und
Entlastungen für die Breite der
Bevölkerung zu finanzieren gerade in
einer Krise muss gelten wer einen
Beitrag leisten kann der übernimmt
Verantwortung wer Unterstützung braucht
der bekommt sie und so machen wir aus
dem viel herbei beschworenen Winter der
Wut ein Winter des Solidarität
und ich bin mir sicher ich habe es in
den letzten Wochen schon immer wieder in
Medien gehört wir werden von Ihnen hier
heute hören das reicht alles nicht das
zu wenig und zu spät aber ich finde die
Union muss sich ehrlich gesagt mal
entscheiden denn am Montag fordert die
Union Steuerentlastungen für wohlhabende
am Dienstag beschwert sie sich über zu
viele Schulden und am Mittwoch sagt sie
dass wir mehr Entlastung brauchen das
macht alles keinen Sinn das wissen wir
auch selbst dieses Finanz wo du wäre
ehrlich gesagt lustig wenn die Lage
nicht so verdammt ernst wäre und deshalb
ist es glaube ich gerade ein Zeichen
dafür dass es gut ist dass wir und nicht
sie Regierungsverantwortung tragen denn
die Menschen diesen Land die brauchen
keine belanglosen aneinandergeraten
Sprechblasen die brauchen konkrete
Lösung und die bekommen Sie mit der
Strom und mit der gaspreisbremse
doch wir gehen darüber noch einen
Schritt hinaus wir arbeiten als
Regierung allen voran Robert Habeck Tag
für Tag Windrad für Windrad daran dass
wir unabhängiger werden von fossilen
Energien denn es ist klar dass wir jetzt
alles geben müssen um Menschen in Zeiten
einer fossilen Inflation finanziell zu
unterstützen aber es ist auch klar dass
der Weg zu bezahlbarer Energie nur mit
Effizienz und mit erneuerbaren Energien
mit Wind und Sonne geht deshalb ist die
Energiewende eine Frage des
Klimaschutzes sie seine Frage der
Freiheit doch die Energiewende ist auch
eine Frage des sozialen Gerechtigkeit
ich habe gestartet mit dem Angriffskrieg
von Vladimir Putin sein Ziel war es
unsere Solidarität zu brechen und auch
unser Land zu spalten und ich glaube
nach diesem Jahr können wir ganz klar
sagen Vladimir Putin hat die Stärke
unserer Demokratie unterschätzt denn wir
stehen weiterhin an der Seite der
Ukraine wir machen uns unabhängig von
russischen fossilen und wir stärken
jetzt ganz konkret mit der Strom und
gaspreisbremse den Zusammenhalt in
diesem Land kurz um können wir nach
einem Jahr sagen wir lassen uns nicht
spalten
vielen Dank
soweit die Kater lang nächster Redner
kommt jetzt aus der Fraktion der cdu/cs
wo es ist Andreas Jung er ist Sprecher
für Klimaschutz und Energie und äußert
sich ebenfalls zum Thema Strom und
gaspreisbremse es gibt ja noch
Entschließungsanträge der Union am Ende
dieser Debatte
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich
möchte in frau Präsidentin zunächst
herzlich danken für Ihre Würdigung von
annemarie Renger und von Wolfgang
Schäuble wir haben größten Respekt von
diesen Lebensleistungen und der stehende
Applaus des ganzen Hauses hat gezeigt
dass ich für viel mehr als die
Abgeordnete Unionsfraktion spreche wenn
ich sage lieber Herr Dr Schäuble wir
sind stolz dass sie einer von uns sind
dr schäuble ist mit den 50 Jahren länger
dabei als wir alle Sie Herr Dr schäublem
nach dem 24 Februar gesagt Sie haben
seit sie politisch tätig sind keine
schwere Krise erlebt wir haben wieder
Krieg mitten in Europa und es geht um
Frieden und Freiheit für den wir ein zu
stehen haben aber es geht auch um die
Bekämpfung der Energiekrise die uns
trifft und darum geht es hier dann sind
wichtige Fortschritte gemacht worden
indem wir mitgewirkt haben mit dem
Füllen der Gasspeicher mit dem
Beschleunigen der LMG Terminals aber
genauso gilt wir sind noch nicht über
den Berg wir brauchen weiter die volle
Konsequenz und alle Möglichkeiten der
Energieversorgung zu sichern um alle
Potentiale Potenziale der Einsparung zu
nutzen da brauchen wir volle
Konsequenzen ich wüsste deutlich sagen
für diesen und für den nächsten Winter
brauchen wir auch noch mehr Konsequenzen
wir
erleben seit spätestens im Frühjahr eine
Explosion der Energiepreise und darauf
braucht es eine starke Antwort und meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren der
Bundesregierung das ist der Punkt da
haben sie zu viel Zeit verstreichen
lassen sie haben ihr erstes
Entlastungspaket im Sommer ohne
Anschlussregelung auslaufen lassen und
als Olaf Scholz dann des jubeln never
walk alone aus rief sind sie zunächst in
die falsche Richtung los marschiert mit
der gasumlage wollten sie die Preise
zunächst erhöhen viel zu spät ist denn
die gastkommission eingesetzt worden
erst im September und das ist der Grund
warum diese Bremsen nicht vor dem Winter
kommen sondern erst nach dem Winter und
das ist der Grund warum sie sich selbst
und ein Zeitdruck gesetzt haben den dazu
geführt hat dass um 0:25 Uhr in der
Nacht auf gestern den zuständigen
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
ein Konvolut von 400 Seiten mit
Änderungsanträgen zugestellt wurden
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren das
steht einer seriösen Behandlung dieses
gesetzespaketes heute entgegen und wäre
es ihnen verlangt
wäre es ihnen vor lang wirklich darum
gegangen sind Zusammenhalt beschworen
hier eine nicht einfach nur ihre
Mehrheit zu nutzen die sie haben soll
eine Mehrheit über die
Regierungskoalition hinauszusuchen da
hätten sie wohl die größte
Oppositionspartei von 0,25 in der
letzten Nacht beteiligt
wir haben Respekt vor der Arbeit der
gastkommission und wir unterstützen es
soweit ihre Ergebnisse umgesetzt wurde
um durch diesen Winter zu kommen um dort
wo Menschen Betriebe unter gestiegenen
Preisen leiden jetzt zu helfen
ich sage das deutlich aber genauso
deutlich sage ich wir kritisieren das wo
sie abweichend von den Empfehlungen der
gastkommissionen des betrifft gerade die
Industrie die Industrie wird mit den
Regelungen die sie aufgebaut haben mit
Hürden mit Anforderungen mit Begrenzung
da werden beide Teile der Industrie kann
der energieintensiven Industrie diese
Preis Bremsen überhaupt nicht die
Anspruch nehmen können und deshalb
konterkariert ihre Umsetzung das doch
auch von ihnen ausgerufene Ziel jetzt
die industrielle Substanz unseres Landes
sind industriellen Kern zu sichern da
geht's um Tausende von Arbeitsplätze es
geht um Wertschöpfung in unserem Land es
geht um Lieferketten ja es geht um die
Zusammenhalt unseres Landes genau an
diesem Punkt in der konterkarieren Sie
die Ergebnisse der eigenen Kommission
ihre eigenen Ansagen und es setzt
die Industrie die Arbeitsplätze die
Wertschöpfung in Deutschland in dieser
Krise auf den Spiel auf das Spielen
deshalb nur für einen schweren Fehler
sie waren es Herr Habig derjenige der
gesagt hat wir werden die Kosten
Dämpfung des Problems zur Kostendämpfung
des Programmes werden wir öffnen für
Mittelstand und Handwerk ich stelle fest
es gibt heute keinerlei Antwort auf die
Bäckerei die umgestellt hat auf Pellets
die jetzt unter der Preissteigerung
genauso leidet da gibt es weiter Lücken
in ihrem Programm und dabei darf es
nicht bleiben sie müssen da nachbessern
und letzte Bemerkung über die Frau lang
weil die Frau lang die erneuerbaren
Energien angesprochen hat was sie
Vorleben sie haben nachgebessert aber es
bleibt eine Bremse für erneuerbare
Energien sie konnte Karrieren das was
sie mit dem osterpaket auf dem Weg
bringen wollten Beschleunigung der
erneuerbaren Energien Abschöpfung von
fiktiven Erträgen statt tatsächlichen
gewinnen das ist das Gegenteil dessen
was wir jetzt brauchen zu Beschleunigung
sie respektieren nicht dort wo
Investitionen gemacht werden in anderen
Ländern kann es angerechnet werden da
werden die privilegiert die investieren
hier werden Investitionen zurückgestellt
in der er Branche ist die Rede von ein
Schildbürgerstreich es werden klagen
angekündigt ja wir brauchen eine
beschleunigen Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien und den konterkarieren Sie mit
diesem Paket herzlichen Dank
soweit Andreas Jung von der
Unionsfraktion
der noch einmal die Position seiner
Fraktion zur Strom und
gaspreisbremse
spezifiziert hat nächster Redner ist
Matthias von der SPD im
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitz
zuständig für das Thema ich glaube es
ist ein gutes Zeichen dass nach dem
Gedenken und den Ehrungen wir dieses
Thema hier heute als ersten Punkt auf
der Tagesordnung haben denn die
Ampelkoalition beweist mit diesem
Rettungsschirm das Politik gestalten
kann und dass wir gerade in diesen
Zeiten Sicherheit schaffen können und
das machen wir heute nach vielen Wochen
Beratung durch die Kommission durch die
Regierung dieses Parlament gibt heute
weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung und der
Wirtschaft in Deutschland Sicherheit mit
den Energiepreisen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und Herr Kollege jung ja Sie können
kritisieren überall und einige Punkte
auf die werde ich noch eingehen aber Sie
müssen auch hier sagen dass sie den
Ursprung die Grundlage für das alles
überhaupt nicht mitgetragen haben sie
haben gegen die 200 Milliarden gestimmt
die überhaupt die Voraussetzungen sind
dass wir das machen worum es hier heute
geht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich habe vor zwei Wochen einige Punkte
angesprochen die meiner Fraktion sehr
wichtig gewesen sind in den letzten 14
Tagen noch mal zu beraten ich bin froh
dass wir diese Punkte jetzt im
parlamentarischen Verfahren als
selbstbewusste Fraktionen auch geklärt
haben für uns war es richtig und wichtig
dass wir all die auch im Blick haben die
nicht nur von Gas oder von Fernwärme
abhängig sind sondern gerade die die Öl
und Pellets beziehen und ich weiß es ist
eine riesen Herausforderung weil wir
hier keine festen Versorgungsstrukturen
haben sondern auf Antragsverfahren
abstellen müssen aber dass die ähnlich
gestellt werden wie die gastron wo wir
sagen ja das Doppelte ist zu tragen aber
was darüber hinausgeht da helfen hilft
der Staat das ist eine Form von
Gerechtigkeit und ich erwarte das Bund
und Länder jetzt die Wege finden um hier
die Gerechtigkeit auch zu realisieren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und es ist richtig gewesen dass wir
beim Biogas und der Frage der
Abschöpfung auch noch mal nachjustiert
haben hier die Freibeträge angehoben
haben und kleine Anlagen rausnehmen aus
der
übergewinn-besteuerung dieses ist eine
Energieform die wir jetzt brauchen und
auch hier ist der parlamentarische
Eingriff dringend richtig und notwendig
gewesen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ja und dann bin ich bei Ihnen Herr
Kollege jung sie haben Recht wir werden
sehr genau aufpassen müssen dass das was
wir uns vorgenommen haben auch wirkt es
ist aber nicht die Bundesregierung
gewesen die beim
industrie-preis interveniert hat sondern
es sind Vorgaben der Europäischen
Kommission die uns verpflichten
bestimmte Voraussetzungen einzuziehen
und hier sage ich ganz deutlich das
werden wir uns angucken an welchen
Stellen wir hier gegebenenfalls
nachjustieren müssen das ist ein
lernendes Verfahren es gibt keine
Blaupause wir sind bereit gegebenenfalls
nachzusteuern wenn wir mehr Punkte sehen
wonach gesteuert werden muss liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir werden uns garantiert nicht
zurücklehnen sondern Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die Aufgaben
der nächsten Wochen sind klar skizziert
bei Kriseninterventionen darf es nicht
bleiben ich glaube es hat sie genauso
geschmerzt wie mich dass wir zum
Beispiel bei der Gewinnabschöpfung nicht
berücksichtigen konnte konnten wenn in
erneuerbare Energien investiert werden
konnte der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien analog zu dem was wir bei
lng-terminals jetzt schaffen muss der
Schlüssel sein dass wir dort maximal das
erreichen um Energie Souveränität
tatsächlich in diesem Land hinzubekommen
die Aufgaben liegen wieder vor uns sie
liegen nicht hinter uns und wir werden
uns als Sozialdemokratie dem mit voller
Kraft Stellen vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
nach dem stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der SPD-Fraktion kommt jetzt Steffen
Portrait von der AFD zum Zug
in der Rede bzw mit der Rede zur
energiepreisbremse und dafür sind beide
Bremsen gemeint die gaspreisbremse wie
auch die strompreisbremse
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren das
Abrissunternehmen Ampelkoalition
marschiert weiter in Richtung Energie
und sozialpolitischen Abgrund und in den
Haushalt tierischen Wahnsinn die Summen
der transferzahlung sind nicht mehr real
gedeckt wir haben deshalb eine Inflation
von 10% um mit dem daraus resultierenden
realen Schrumpfen der nicht mehr
rückzahlbaren Schulden den Bürgern
diesen Werteverlust
aufzuhalten wie ein Diktaturen werden
die selbst geschaffene Mangelwirtschaft
verwaltet und die Bürger geschöpft meine
Damen und Herren
planwirtschaftlich werden Löcher mit
Steuergeldern jetzt gestopft die wir in
einer funktionierenden sozialen
Marktwirtschaft ohne diese dumme und
naive Sanktionspolitik gar nicht hätten
trotz Preisbremse werden die überhöhten
Energiekosten ja doch bezahlt aber eben
jetzt wie auch schon bei der sogenannten
Energiewende von den Steuerzahlern die
Situation ließen sich sofort entschärfen
mit Kernenergie mit Kohleverstromung mit
Beendigung der nutzlosen Sanktionen aber
weil die Ampel das nicht tut müssen wir
konzentrieren dass wir hier mit einer
Veruntreuung von Steuergeldern haben zu
tun haben
die leider nicht mehr dem Volk
verpflichtete Ampel scheffelt das Geld
der deutschen über die eigentlichen
Energiekosten hinaus mit vollen Händen
ins Ausland in die USA für überteuertes
Flüssiggas nach Indien für russisches Öl
jetzt nach Frankreich und Belgien für
russisches
LNG und Russland bekommt trotzdem
weiterhin Geld obwohl die Propaganda der
Ampel genau das verhindern wollte mit
diesen Sanktionen aber das links grüne
Abbruchunternehmen Ampelkoalition macht
uns dadurch leider zu geißeln ihrer
heuchlerischen
moralpropaganda meine Damen und Herren
und normal
wäre eine Beendigung wenn Dinge nicht
funktionieren aber eben leider nicht bei
den Links Grünen die Verhinderung der
niedrigen Strompreise muss also einen
Grund haben
und der liegt wohl in der Absicht uns
Deutsche finanziell zu schädigen unsere
Wirtschaftskraft quasi zu verdünnen wie
es wahrscheinlich der ehemalige grüne
Kriegsminister Joschka Fischer gesagt
hätte quasi zu verdünnen und ein
Instrument dafür ist es nicht direkt
preiswertes russisches Öl und Gas
einzukaufen sondern über Umwege und
Zwischenhändler und damit kann dann
diese trümmertruppe nämlich zusätzlich
Geld auseinander schaffen mit der
Einschaltung z.B das US-amerikanische
Unternehmens konokor Philips für
katarisches Gas der belgischen fluxi der
französischen Totem energies
meine Damen und Herren mit einem
Straftatbestand steuergeldverständigung
säße vermutlich die gesamte
Bundesregierung auf der
Anklagebank die bröhe zahlen die Bürger
zahlen brach ihre hohen Steuern und die
Regierung verschwendet sie regelmäßig
das muss aufhören und deshalb wird es
mit der AFD diesen Straftatbestand
Steuergeldverschwendung geben
dass
links grüne Politbüro löst mit seinen
planwirtschaftlichen
transferzahlung nicht nur nicht die
Probleme in unserem Land sondern sie
verschärft sie auch für die Zukunft die
preisdämpfung beim Kunden hier jetzt in
diesem Gesetzespaket bei uns vorliegend
kodifiziert löst nicht nur die Probleme
sondern sie bewirkt einen Anreiz für
unbegründete Preiserhöhung bei den
Unternehmen selbst bei den Lieferanten
im nächsten Jahr entfällt russisches
rohrleitungsgas komplett und der Ersatz
fehlt die Betteltour von Scholz und
Harbeck waren bekanntlich nicht sehr
ergiebig und wenn die Weltwirtschaft
wieder anzieht ja dann wird überall in
den je nachgefragt und es wird für uns
auch knapper und teuer meine Damen und
Herren die Schädigung der Deutschland AG
geht leider weiter die Menschen in
unserem Land werden ist aber erkennen
sich wehren und dann ist es Schluss mit
dieser gegen unsere Menschen gerichtete
Politik
sie konnten sich natürlich nicht wieder
enthalten hier was zu sagen
es war tatsächlich das Ende der Rede von
Steffen Portrait von der AFD mit
historischen vergleichen und Ausflügen
in die deutsche Geschichte nächste
Redner Lukas Köhler von der FDP auch
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
zuständig für die Fragen von Strom und
gaspreisbremsen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben uns
vor nicht einmal zehn Monaten also noch
nicht mal vor einem Jahr hier darüber
unterhalten welche Auswirkungen dieser
Krieg hat und welche Auswirkungen dieser
Krieg haben und wir haben damals
festgestellt es wird nicht einfach und
natürlich ist es nicht einfach aber wir
haben auch damals schon sehr klar gesagt
alles was wir können werden wir hier in
diesem Hohen Haus mit der Ampel tun um
die Regierung zu unterstützen um gegen
diesen Krieg zu arbeiten um dafür zu
sorgen dass der Mittelstand erhalten
dass sie Industrie erhalten dass wir
dafür sorgen dass Experten nicht so
treffen wie sie können wenn wir nichts
tun würden und wir haben immer gesagt
wir werden die Ukraine unterstützen und
das ist nach wie vor richtig es bleibt
richtig die Ukraine zu unterstützen auch
wenn es nicht einfach ist 200 Milliarden
neue Schulden aufzunehmen dafür zu
sorgen dass wir viel Geld an die
Menschen verteilen auch wenn es nicht
einfach ist dafür zu sorgen dass wir uns
zu sehen dass wir in eine neue Zeit
eintreten müssen wenn es um die
Energieversorgung ist und es ist
trotzdem richtig die Menschen zu
unterstützen und es ist trotzdem richtig
dafür zu sorgen dass die Ukraine
unterstützt bleibt
wir haben mit der Strom- und
gaspreisbremse jetzt ein einfaches
schnelles und wirksames Instrument
vorgelegt ist es ein perfektes
Instrument nein wie sollen wir in so
kurzer Zeit das perfekte Gesetz machen
Wolfgang Schäuble hat es gerade gesagt
wir können in Schönheit sterben oder wir
können Dinge pragmatisch lösen und ich
finde es richtig dass wir uns für
Pragmatismus entschieden heißt das wir
werden alle wir werden kein Problem mit
diesem Gesetz bekommen nein das heißt es
nicht heißt es dass wir reaktionsfähig
sind ja das beweisen wir jeden Tag wir
beweisen und zeigen jedes Mal dass es
funktioniert dass wir Dinge besser
machen und ich finde es gut und richtig
dass wir in diesem Gesetz die
unterschiedlichen Anreize sind dass wir
dafür sorgen dass der Mittelstand
entlassen wird gut durch das Jahr dass
wir für KMU ist noch mal ein
härtefallfonds auflesen liegen gemeinsam
mit den Ländern dass wir dafür sorgen
dass die Industrie wirklich bei ihren
Energiekosten unterstützt
und gleichzeitig müssen wir den Spar
Anreiz aufrecht erhalten ich finde das
darf in dieser Debatte nicht vergessen
werden wenn wir zu wenig Gas sparen dann
reden wir in ein paar wenigen Monaten
nicht mehr über die Probleme eines
solchen Gesetzes oder die
Herausforderung vor der wir gerade steht
dann reden wir über eine gasmangelage
und das darf uns nicht passieren
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
sprechen und es ist auch richtig dass
wir diejenigen zum Beispiel die
Erneuerbaren die extreme Gewinne in
diesem Jahr eingefahren haben wegen dem
Markt die sein dass wir haben dass wir
da dafür sorgen dass die Zufalls Gewinne
und es ist trotzdem richtig dass wir
beim Biogas viel rausgeholt haben dafür
dass da die Härten nicht kommen dass wir
dafür gesorgt haben dass wir weiterhin
flexible Leistungen am Markt haben denn
auf der einen Seite sparen ist richtig
aber auf der anderen Seite müssen wir
heute schon in die Zukunft denken wir
müssen heute darüber nachdenken woher
kommt das Gas in der Zukunft und ja da
darf auch die deutsche Gasförderung
nicht ausgeschlossen sein aber es darf
natürlich nicht dabei enden wir müssen
in der Erneuerbare Energien investieren
wir müssen aber auch ein neues Strom
aktiv sein Schaffen wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Industrie dass der
Mittelstand dass die Wirtschaft dass die
Menschen in diesem Land mit günstiger
Energie versorgt werden wenn wir das
alles hinbekommen dann sind wir auf
einem wirklich guten Weg zum Schluss
möchte ich noch mal Robert Habeck und
dem bmwk für dieses Gesetz danke das war
ein heißer und schneller rett und ich
glaube wir haben hier wirklich selbst
vorgelegt vielen Dank
soweit Lukas Köhler von der FDP dem Dank
an Robert Herbig wird sich sicherlich
der nächste Redner nicht anschließen
Klaus Ernst von der Fraktion die Linken
erst auch gleichzeitig Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
federführend für das Gesetzesvorhaben
so meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
verlangen sie haben gerade gesagt das
war bei uns eigentlich nie billig
der erste grandiose Fehlschluss den sie
da machen
der niedrige Gaspreis war mit
Ursache dieses Wohlstands dieser
Republik in den letzten 50 Jahren und zu
diesem und von diesem Wohlstand haben
auch sie profitiert sie konnten
studieren
der industriell die industrielle Basis
beruhte zum einen auf der Energie und
zum anderen auf den gut ausgebildeten
Leuten auch vernünftigen Löhnen das
heute in Frage zu stellen und zu tun als
wäre es nicht gewesen die schlichtweg an
der Realität vollkommen vorbei und ich
freue mich übrigens dass ich unsere
exkanzlerin tatsächlich weigert sich für
diese Politik zu entschuldigen ne das
sage ich ihnen weil ist sie freuen sich
ja darüber das ist nicht gut oder
irgendwie das ist nicht tot ich finde
das gut dass sie das nicht tut dass sie
zu diesem Punkt sich bekennt ich würde
mich freuen von der CDU würden das mehr
zu sehen
zweitens wir machen jetzt ein
gaspreisdeckel
also ein gaspreisbremse ich weiß nicht
ob ihnen verdoppeln trotz dieses trotz
dieses in dieser Bremse verdoppeln wir
den Gaspreis für 80 Prozent des Gases
wird
80 Prozent des Gases ist doch
schlichtweg doppelt so teuer wie vorher
80%, und den Rest und den Rest den Töpfe
den Rest machen wir überhaupt nichts der
der das ist der Rest ist Marktpreis für
verdoppeln die Energiepreise beim Gas
und beim Strom 35 %. das ist die
Realität ihres denken ich weiß nicht
warum sie sich so aufregen lassen Sie
doch ihr eigenes Gesetz unterstützt doch
so drin und dann sage ich Ihnen das
führt eben nicht dazu das würde ihm
Ergebnis nicht dazu dass eigentlich das
passieren sollte was die Bundesregierung
mit den Amtszeit versprochen hat nämlich
Schaden vom deutschen Volk abzuwenden
ist kein Schaden ist dann weiß ich nicht
noch was der Schaden ist meine Damen und
Herren
und ich sage Ihnen auch dass und ich
sage Ihnen auch dass aus diesem Gründen
das aus diesen Gründen wir keine
gasbremse machen sondern mit ihrer
Politik wird dazu beitragen dass
insbesondere die industrielle Basis
dieses Landes gefährdet wird danke
natürlich Aufmerksamkeit
ja für jeden und jede noch mal zum
Mitschreiben im Gesetz steht die ersten
80 Prozent des bisherigen Verbrauchs mit
12 Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim
Gasverbrauch und 40 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde beim Stromverbrauch für
die Privathaushalte ich sage es noch
einmal die ersten 80% des bisherigen
Vertrauen verbraucht nächste Redner
Andreas an Autos von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
frau Präsidentin
Herr Ernst ich muss mit ihnen anfangen
es ist traurig und ich hätte das gerne
anders gemacht aber es ist einfach nicht
möglich daran vorbeizugehen was sie
gerade gesagt haben sie sind Vorsitzende
des Ausschusses für Klima und Energie
und wenn Sie hier sprechen kriegen sie
Applaus ausschließlich aus einer
Fraktion nämlich von ganz rechts von der
AFD ich weiß nicht wohin sich die Linke
entwickeln will aber das was wir hier
erlebt haben sein weiterer Tiefpunkt und
ist traurig es tut mir leid
wir decken
wir Deckeln heute Gas und Strompreise
für Millionen von Menschen für Millionen
von Unternehmen für Krankenhäuser
Schulen Kitas Kultureinrichtungen
soziale Einrichtungen und das ist ein
Handeln in einer Dimension die so in
Deutschland noch nie dagewesen ist eine
klare Ansage dass wir uns nicht
erpressen lassen dass wir uns nicht
erpressen lassen mit Energie als Waffe
und dass wir uns schon gar nicht
erpressen lassen von einem Diktator
namens Wladimir Putin und ich sage Ihnen
mal was das in der Praxis bedeutet zum
Beispiel für eine vierköpfige Familie
100 Quadratmeter Wohnfläche diese
Familie spart durch die Deckelungen bei
Gas und Strom über
1500 € im Jahr das ist die Antwort die
wir geben auf Wladimir Putin auch an die
hier im Deutschen Bundestag die
versuchen diese die Menschen in so einer
schwierigen Lage aufzuwiegen und vor
allem ist es die Antwort die wir geben
an all die Menschen da draußen nicht
verdient haben dass wir in dieser Krise
solidarisch sind und Probleme gelöst
kriegen
Fairness und Gerechtigkeit das hat uns
bei der Ausgestaltung der Bremsen
geleitet und deswegen ist es ein Gebot
der Vernunft dass diese Maßnahmen dass
die Bremsen versteuert werden weil die
die mehr haben die können natürlich auch
etwas mehr beitragen die Menschen die
sehr wenig haben die brauchen jetzt den
vollen Entlastungsbetrag und deswegen
haben wir eingeführt dass die Bremsen
versteuert werden und schaffen so ein
Prinzip von Gerechtigkeit und
Solidarität auch in dieser Krise
und das gilt selbstverständlich auch für
Vorstände für die Manager von
Unternehmen die nun hohe
Millionenbeträge an Unterstützung
kriegen können und ich sage es einmal
sehr sehr klar Staatshilfen in dieser
Krise sind richtig und sie sind
notwendig und gleichzeitig muss dabei
aber doch klar sein dass diese Hilfen in
die Betriebe fließen müssen dass diese
Investitionen in die Unternehmen in die
Zukunft fließen müssen in den Standort
Deutschland wir subventionieren nicht
die konnten von
Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden oder
Vorstandsvorsitzenden wir wollen nicht
dass Dividenden dann ausgezahlt werden
wenn hohe Millionenbeträge vom
Steuerzahler an die Unternehmen geht das
was wir tun ist Zukunft zu finanzieren
das was wir tun ist zu stützen um daraus
für Unternehmen eine Perspektive zu
erreichen und das ist das was wir mit
dieser Preisbremse umsetzen können
eines darf uns bei all dieser aktuellen
Lage nicht passieren wir dürfen bei der
Bewältigung der Probleme nicht die
größte Krise unserer Zeit die Klimakrise
aus den Augen verlieren und darum ist
Nachhaltigkeit und darum ist
Klimaneutralität genau die Perspektive
die wir brauchen um aus dieser Krise
wieder herauszukommen und deswegen haben
wir in den Verhandlungen dafür gesorgt
dass die mögliche Förderung für
erneuerbare bei den Ausschreibungen um
25% angehoben wird weil wir wissen dass
wir jetzt einen massiven Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien brauchen um die
Krise zu überwinden raus aus Putins Gas
und raus aus putinsöl muss heißen rein
in die Erneuerbaren und auch das machen
wir mit diesen Paket und auch das ist
Teil der Lösung die wir hier heute
vorlegen
wir investieren in Solidarität und
Fairness in dieser Krise und
gleichzeitig investieren wir in
Nachhaltigkeit und klimatalität um mit
Deutschland aus dieser Krise schnell und
nachhaltig wieder herauszukommen danke
schön
Andreas outrecht von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen mit seinem Debattenbeitrag
stellvertretender Fraktionsvorsitzender
bei Bündnis 90 Sekunden diese Funktion
hat auch Jens Spahn in der frühere
Bundesgesundheitsminister in der cdu/csu
und Kollegen wir haben gestern gehört
unter anderem von Frau dröge Herr dürr
sie wünschen sich eine konstruktive
Opposition und die kriegen sie seit
Monaten die Union als die Union als
konstruktive Opposition hat seit mehr
märz die Union hat seit März die
wirksamste aller Preis Bremsen gefordert
eine Ausweitung des Angebots umso mehr
Strom produziert wird desto niedriger
der Preis sie haben den Menschen
monatelang erzählt morgens im Radio
abends in der Tagesschau wir hätten
keinen Strom Problem sie haben erst
gelacht als wir gesagt haben mehr Kohle
ans Netz sie haben unsere Anträge für
mehr Biogas und Windenergie abgelehnt
sie haben sich bei der Kernenergie
unseren Vorschlägen
psychologisch verweigert aktuell
übrigens Frau lang wird fast zwei
Drittel unsere Stroms wochenweise aus
fossilen Brennstoffen Kohle und Gas
produziert wie stellen Sie sich das
eigentlich vor wenn dann die drei
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet werden für
nächsten Winter dass wir noch mehr Gas
verbrennen lassen Sie die drei
Kernkraftwerke in dieser Krise in den
nächsten zwei Wintern am Netz
die Union als konstruktive Opposition
sagt ihnen seit dem Sommer dass sie
Haushalte und Wirtschaft schnell und
wirksam entlasten sollten schnell durch
eine Senkung der Mehrwert und
Energiesteuern das haben sie bisher nur
beim Gas gemacht das sollte jetzt auch
vor allem beim Öl passieren und
Millionen Haushalte zu entlasten sie
machen es nicht schnell und wirksam für
diejenigen das sind Millionen Haushalte
in Deutschland die mit Öl heizen vor
allem im ländlichen Raum sie machen
irgendeinen vor von dem bis heute keiner
weiß ob überhaupt irgendwo eine Hilfe
ankommt sie machen Millionen Haushalte
zu Antragstellern anstatt ist am
bürokratisch und einfach zu machen sie
haben stattdessen
sie haben das stattdessen monatelang
Zeit mit einer gasumlage vergeudet die
in der Krise den Preis noch erhöht hätte
dann haben sie eine gaskommission
eingesetzt spät aber immerhin die
Ergebnisse haben sie zelebriert und nun
setzen Sie die Ergebnisse der Kommission
so um das weite Teile der Wirtschaft sie
gar nicht werden in Anspruch nehmen
können oder wollen dass sie entlasten
wollen ist richtig und ja das haben wir
immer gefordert aber sie machen es
bürokratisch halbherzig spät und
hektisch der BDI-Präsident Russwurm der
Mitglied der gaskommission war sagte
gestern er wäre tief enttäuscht die
Politik lege mit ihrer Ignoranz
gegenüber den betrieblichen Realitäten
die Axt an die Grundpfeiler des
Standortes Deutschland
verbraucherschützer sind enttäuscht die
Gewerkschaften alarmiert eine
konstruktive Opposition kann solchen
Befunden nicht zustimmen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wer wer eine konstruktive Opposition
will Herr Kollege gremmels der sollte
sie einbinden sie haben in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten trotz mehrfacher
Angebote nicht dass ernsthafte Gespräch
mit uns gesucht sie haben uns im
Gegenteil Dienstagnacht über 400
seitenänderungsanträge geschickt die
Mittwochmorgen im Ausschuss beschlossen
werden sollten im Ausschuss konnten sie
teilweise selbst ihre Regelungen für Öl
und Pellets zum Beispiel nicht wirklich
nachvollziehbar erläutern der ich war
digital zugeschaltet Herr Kollege Kruse
das Schöne das schöne an Hybriden
Sitzung ist man kann digital teilnehmen
und dabei habe ich gemerkt Herr Kollege
Kruse der zuständige Energieminister war
im energieausschuss einmal mehr nicht da
und Herr Habeck es ist schon bezeichnet
dass heute hier in dieser Debatte bei
diesem Thema sie nicht reden wer von
seinem eigenen Gesetz überzeugt ist der
kann es auch hier vom Deutschen
Bundestag vertreten und muss sich den
Gesundheitsminister schicken um die
Energiepolitik der Regierung zu erklären
Liebe Kolle und Kollegen
statt die konstruktive Opposition zu
beschimpfen statt dieses teilweise
aggressive mimimi dass wir gestern vor
allem in der Debatte erlebt haben
sollten Sie lieber schauen wie wir zu
einer konstruktiven Regierung kommen wie
wir es schaffen ja in einem guten
Gespräch und Sie können das für sich
entscheiden sie können für sich
entscheiden sie haben die Mehrheit sie
ziehen das hier durch das ist völlig
okay sie gutes Recht aber erwarten Sie
dann nicht dass wir da ein Mithaftung
gehen denn die einzige Bremse die seit
Monaten wirklich wirkt ist leider die
Ampel selbst sie bremsen mehr Angebot
beim Strom und damit niedrige Preise
politisch aus sie bremsen wirklich
wirksame Hilfen für Handwerk Mittelstand
und Industrie und damit für Millionen
Arbeitsplätze aus sie bremsen ein
ordentliches parlamentarisches Verfahren
eine gute Debatte und notwendige
Transparenz aus das Ergebnis ist ein
Gesetz das gut gemeint ist aber nicht
gut gemacht so viel Halbherzigkeit
Bürokratie und Hektik dafür sollten Sie
uns nicht in Verantwortung nehmen wollen
die müssen sie schon selber tragen eine
konstruktive Opposition kann da nicht
zustimmen
soweit Jens Spahn jetzt wird sicherlich
die Gegenrede dazu kommen Verena
Huppertz stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der
SPD-Fraktion ebenso wie in Spanien und
in der Unionsfraktion wird sich jetzt
zum Thema energiepreisbremsen äußern
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
was ein Jahr heute in der letzten
Sitzungswoche des Deutschen Bundestages
beschließen wir ein noch nie dagewesenes
Paket mit Bremsen Gas und Strom so dass
die Wirtschaft aber auch die Haushalte
in diesem Land gut durch diese Krise
kommen und da würde ich mir wünschen
Herr Spahn wenn sie da dann auch mal
zustimmen und nicht dagegen sind denn
bei ihren vorschlägenständen welche
schon wo ganz anders und deswegen ist
das heute ein wichtiger Schritt für
dieses Parlament
und ich möchte hier heute mal auf die
wirtschaftspolitischen Themen eingehen
denn wir erinnern uns noch alle an den
Sommer an die Bäckereien die gesagt
haben ich bekomme ja keine Hilfe weil
ich nicht auf irgendeiner Liste stehe
die kübelliste heißt und weil die Hilfen
nicht für mich greifen und das was wir
jetzt tun das sind unternehmenshilfen
die helfen den großen
Aktiengesellschaften den kleinen
Personengesellschaften egal in welcher
Branche egal wo wir ziehen eine Bremse
ein damit wir in diesem Land noch was zu
transformieren haben nach dieser Krise
und das ist wichtig
aber wir stellen auch Bedingungen an
diese Unterstützungen
zum Beispiel wenn Unternehmen ganz ganz
viele und ganz große Millionenhilfen
bekommen dann erwarten wir auch dass der
Standort gesichert bleibt und die
Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben und dass
man nicht den Koffer mit dem Geld nimmt
und dann woanders das Werk wieder
aufbaut und dafür haben wir uns als
Sozialdemokratie stark gemacht
und es geht auch um Respekt in diesem
Land
das Unternehmen auch ihren Beitrag
leisten dass wir alle gemeinsam gut
durch diese Krise kommen und da kann es
nicht sein wenn ich auf der einen Seite
Steuergelder und ganz viel Staatshilfe
bekomme auf der anderen Seite sage so
jetzt schütte ich doch mal hier die
Gewinne aus und ich erhöh doch mal den
Boni und bevor ich dieses Mandat letztes
Jahr angenommen habe weiß selbst
Unternehmerinnen in der corona-pandemie
war es für uns alle eine schwierige Zeit
und da bin ich nicht hingegangen und
habe mein Gehalt erhöht da habe ich das
Gehalt gekürzt und nicht noch ein Bonus
ausgeschüttet und deswegen haben wir
auch verboten in diesem Gesetz verankert
und das ist auch ein Zeichen des
gemeinsamen Respekts ein Zeichen dass
wir auch gemeinsam unseren Beitrag
leisten müssen
und natürlich sind in diesem Gesetz
viele Berechnungsgrundlagen drin zum
Beispiel das
vorjahreszeiträume bestimmen welcher
Grundbedarf denn zum Beispiel
subventioniert wird und 2021 war für uns
alle kein einfaches Jahr und 2021 fließt
mit rein in diese Berechnung für die
Hotellerie Gastronomie den Einzelhandel
wir hatten staatlich verordnete
lockdowns wir hatten aber auch ich bin
Rheinland-Pfälzerinnen eine
Flutkatastrophe die nicht nur unser
Bundesland sondern auch
Nordrhein-Westfalen und Bayern betroffen
hat und wenn an der einen Seite das
Betriebswerk wegschwemmt oder das
Restaurant nicht öffnen kann da kann ich
nicht sagen 21 war die
Berechnungsgrundlage und das nehmen wir
jetzt und darauf berechnen wir eben die
Hilfen nein wer einmal im Regen
gestanden hat darf nicht ein zweites Mal
im Regen stehen und deswegen werden dort
individuelle Prognosen angelegt und das
haben wir im parlamentarischen Verfahren
jetzt auch noch mal klargestellt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ja das
ist ein dickes Brett und das ist auch
nicht perfekt und der Kollege Mirsch hat
eben schon darauf hingewiesen wir werden
auch noch mal unsere Hausaufgaben
mitnehmen nach Brüssel damit wir schauen
da wo das temporary crisis Framework
also dieses rahmenkorsett was überhaupt
erlaubt was unternehmen auch jetzt an
Hilfe bekommen können dass da wo zum
Beispiel die großen Konzerne die ein
Gewinnrückgang zum Beispiel zeigen
müssen ein ewitter Rückgang ja das passt
noch nicht so richtig gut zusammen und
deswegen wird der Wirtschaftsminister
deswegen wird der Kanzler und wir alle
gemeinsam dafür in Brüssel werden dass
das was wir hier auch bereitstellen auch
ankommt und da hatte ich Sie herzlich
ein dann doch bitte heute mal
zuzustimmen und nicht nur zu sagen was
wäre denn heute ist erstmal ein
wichtiger Tag für die Menschen und die
Wirtschaft in diesem Land damit wir alle
miteinander gut rauskommen vielen
herzlichen Dank
voraussichtlich nächster Redner ist Marc
Bernhard von der AFD er Sprecher für
Bauen und Wohnen und ist auch Mitglied
im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
die AFD wird am Ende dieser Debatte auch
einen Entschließungsantrag und einen
Änderungsantrag zur
strompreisbremse einbringen
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
das Konzept ihrer Energiewende wahres
alle Kohle und Kernkraftwerke
abzuschalten und diese durch
Gaskraftwerke zu ersetzen die hier
überall im Land gebaut werden sollten
so wurden allein Anfang diesen Jahres 10
Gigawatt Leistungen Kern und
Kohlekraftwerken abgeschaltet das ist
genauso wie wenn man ganz
Baden-Württemberg den Stecker ziehen
würde seitdem Beginn des um keine Kriegs
ist die aber jedem klar dass dieser Plan
so nicht mehr funktionieren wird und es
ist jetzt 10 Monate her und was haben
Sie von der Regierung in diesen zehn
Monaten gemacht um die Energieversorgung
unseres Landes sicherzustellen ganz
offensichtlich nicht sinnvolles denn
sonst müssten die Bürger heute nicht den
doppelten Strompreis 150 fahren Gaspreis
bezahlen sie hätten sofort mit
Kriegsbeginn handeln müssen denn
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Kernenergie
aussetzen und alle nur wenige Wochen
vorher vom Netz genommenen Kraftwerke
wieder ein Netz nehmen und dann hätten
wir diese ganze Energie Katastrophe hier
heute nämlich gar nicht
die haben also diese aktuellen Notlage
sei es mutwillig oder durch Unfähigkeit
sehenden Auges herbeigeführt und deshalb
muss den Menschen jetzt auch dringend
geholfen werden denn in Deutschland darf
niemand frieren aber was sie hier machen
was sie hier machen ist eine reine
Symptombekämpfung die am grundsätzlichen
Problem überhaupt gar nichts ändert von
ihren so von ihren sogenannten 200
Milliarden Euro Abwehr Schirm kostet
allein die Strom und gaspreisbremse 100
Milliarden wie viele Winter sollen in
die Bürger diese 100 Milliarden für den
Strom und Gaspreis Deckel bezahlen frage
ich Sie das ist doch nichts anderes als
eine reine
steuerverbrennungsmaschine die Menschen
müssen nämlich immer noch für 80% ihr
Verbrauchs den dreifachen Gaspreis wie
im letzten Jahr bezahlen und für den
Rest in unbegrenzter Höhe die restlichen
20 Prozent unbegrenzt nach oben was wie
hier brauchen ist eine dauerhafte und
nachhaltige Lösung nämlich ganz einfach
das zu tun wogegen sich diese Regierung
seit zehn Monaten rigoros weigert
nämlich alle verfügbaren Kern und
Kohlekraftwerke wieder ins Netz zu
nehmen oder weiterlaufen zu lassen
eigene Gasvorkommen nutzen und vor allem
vor allem nicht aus teurem Gas Strom zu
erzeugen und diesen dann in riesigen
Mengen ins Ausland zu exportieren
helfen sie den Menschen wirklich bringen
sie die 2021 abgeschalteten Kraftwerke
wieder ins Netz und der Strompreis
halbiert sich von heute auf morgen von
ganz alleine
[Applaus]
soweit mag Bernhard von der
afd-fraktion
nächster Redner laut Rednerliste ist
jetzt Michael Kruse von der FDP er ist
der energiepolitische Sprecher der
Partei
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich bin
Volkswirt und ich bin freie Demokrat und
Preisbremse und gewinnabschöpfungen sind
exakt das Gegenteil davon wofür ich mich
dafür habe in dieses Parlament wählen
lassen sie sind nicht treffsicher und
sie schaffen auch nicht die richtigen
Anreize nämlich dafür zu sorgen dass
Menschen bei stark steigenden
Energiepreisen auch die richtigen
Anpassungen vornehmen und sich an die
hohen Preise eben anpassen deshalb ist
für mich vollkommen klar diese
Instrumente dürfen nur in einer Notlage
wie der aktuellen eingesetzt werden und
Sie müssen wieder enden sobald dies
möglich ist nur der russische
energiekrieg gegen Deutschland
rechtfertigt einen Einsatz ein
temporären Einsatz derartiger
Instrumente
und lieber Herr Kollege Spahn ich
wundere mich etwas über ihrem partiellen
Gedächtnisverlust ich weiß dass die
corona-gesetzgebung in den letzten
Jahren unter Eder ihrer Federführung
Teil so hektisch war dass die Änderungen
noch im Ausschuss vorgetragen worden
sind und deswegen fände ich es ehrlich
gesagt für eine verantwortungsvolle
Opposition angemessen das Gesetz dass
wir hier vorliegen an seiner Qualität zu
bemessen und nicht daran wie das
Verfahren nun gelaufen ist sie wissen
dass wir sehr schnelle Gesetze machen
beurteilen Sie die Qualität und stimmen
Sie danach ab dann müssten sie diesem
Gesetz nämlich heute zustimmen
die Verunsicherung in ihnen
Energiemärkten ist groß sie hat zu
starken Preisanstiegen geführt dieser
externe Stock bedroht die
Volkswirtschaft und er bedroht auch
viele Menschen in Deutschland in ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Existenz das ist der
Grund warum wir derartige Eingriffe
vornehmen wir entlasten mit diesem
Instrument in einem Ausmaß wie ist das
in der Geschichte Deutschlands meines
Wissens nach noch nicht gegeben hat die
Ampel ist damit die
entlastungskoalition in Deutschland und
dass wir Freie Demokraten besonders viel
Wert auf die Entlastung der Menschen
legen das brauche ich glaube ich an
dieser Stelle nicht zu betonen Herr
Kruse gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
oder Bemerkung aus der AFD Fraktion
Carsten Hilse von der afd-fraktion mit
einer Zwischenfrage vielen Dank Herr
Kruse dass Sie Herr Kollege dass sie die
Zwischenfrage zulassen sie haben ja
gerade schon erwähnt dass sie also gegen
ihre eigene Überzeugung eigentlich
Überzeugung diesem Gesetz hier zustimmen
also dieses mittragen und wir hatten ja
gestern Ausschuss und dort
ja gab es eine absurde Schauspiel Herr
Ernst der Ausschussvorsitzender hat
richtigerweise
gesagt dass laut Geschäftsordnung der
Ausschuss nur dann Beschlussempfehlungen
abgeben darf wenn das wenn es ein
sachlichen Zusammenhang zwischen
verschiedenen Dingen in diesem Gesetz
gibt und sie wissen ja jetzt das ist ein
Omnibus Gesetz ist wo also das
Infektionsschutzgesetz geändert wird
dass also Apotheken also impfen dürfen
das durften sie schon vorher aber eben
erleichtert jetzt würde ich von Ihnen
gerne den sachlichen Zusammenhang
zwischen den impfen in Apotheken und der
gaspreisbremse
erklärt bekommen das wäre sehr nett
vielen Dank
also erste Bemerkung dazu
es schließt sich also der Kreis zu der
Rede des Vorsitzenden Ernst bei dem
wieder Kollege von den Grünen
festgestellt hat ja ausschließlich die
afd-fraktion geklatscht hat ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht wohin das ganze
hier noch führen soll erstens
wenn ich es im spaßel beantworten wollte
würde ich einfach sagen es wird ja einen
Grund geben warum der
Bundesgesundheitsminister gleich noch
spricht und auch der ehemalige
Gesundheitsminister hat ja hier die
Themen Gesundheit und Energie auf eine
ganz interessante Art und Weise
verknüpft nämlich im Verfahren aber ich
möchte Ihnen auch einfach sagen dass das
was wir hier im Moment machen eben
krisengesetzgebung ist dass sie diese
Krise in den letzten zehn Monaten
wollt fast sagen ausgeblendet haben aber
ausgeblendet stimmt ja gar nicht denn
sie hatten ja eine Veranstaltung und
Herr Kollege sie waren auf dieser
Veranstaltung anwesend sie saßen sogar
ganz nah am Mikrofon sie hatten eine
Veranstaltung in diesem Sommer wo sie
darauf gehofft haben dass dieser Winter
eine Katastrophe wird damit Ihnen die
Wählerinnen und Wähler zulaufen und dass
das nicht passiert ist zeigt wir machen
hier genau das Richtige wir sorgen dafür
dass Schaden vom deutschen Volk
abgewendet ist das tun wir im Bereich
der corona-politik und das tun wir im
Bereich der Energiepolitik es ist
bedauerlich es ist eine Schande dass sie
nicht in der Lage sind auch konstruktiv
an diesem Thema mitzuarbeiten und
deswegen werden wir auch weiterhin alles
tun um dieses Land vor Schaden zu
bewahren sie freuen sich in Wahrheit
darüber wenn die Energiespeicher leer
sind sie freuen sich das Putin kein Gas
mehr in Deutschland liefern weil sie
ausschließlich auf ihr eigenes
Punktekonto schaut
machen wir nicht mit wir sind vom
deutschen Volk für das deutsche Volk
gewählt worden meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren Herr Kruse
ich habe eine weitere Zwischenfrage oder
mehr Bemerkung vom Kollegen Ernst aus
der Fraktion DIE LINKE ja gerne also
nach der Intervention von rechts jetzt
auch noch von links Klaus Ernst wurde ja
auch in der Rede von Michael Kruse
angesprochen Klaus Ernst von den Linken
weiß doch angesprochen worden ist das
selbst in einem schiffstück des
Ministeriums der Vermerk darauf stand
Vorsicht sachfremd also das Verfahren
des vergestern hatten in diesem
Ausschuss möchte das noch mal eindeutig
sagen war auch als meiner Sicht nicht in
Ordnung
wir haben eine Fülle von Vorschlägen
bekommen von ihnen zu einem Zeitpunkt wo
es keinem Abgeordneten mehr möglich war
rechtzeitig und einigermaßen sauber
überhaupt zu lesen was sie vorschlagen
selbst über die ganze Nacht
durchgewiesen hätten das ja nach 12 Uhr
eingegangen nach 12 Uhr nachts
eingegangen also ich weiß nicht was sie
daran eigentlich zu verteidigen sie
haben sich in dem Ausschuss entschuldigt
für dieses Verfahren
es wäre angebracht ist auch hier zu tun
und nicht die zu kritisieren die einen
solchen ein solches Verfahren nicht mehr
akzeptieren ich hoffe Herr Kruse das
nicht unternehmen
die letztendlich nicht mit einverstanden
sind dass sie jetzt Gewinne abgeschöpft
Kriegen gegen dieses Gesetz deshalb
klagen weil sie sagen es ist nicht
ordnungsgemäß zustande gekommen wenn das
nämlich wäre dann hätten sie sozusagen
ihr Ziel erreicht sie sagen ja sie sind
im Gesetz eigentlich sowieso nicht
einverstanden aber deshalb wäre es
vielleicht sinnvoller künftig darauf zu
achten dass die Verfahren eingehalten
werden
Klasse ernst ist Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses um den es hier gegen der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
was da gestern besprochen worden ist im
Vorfeld der heutigen Gesetze
gesetzesentscheidung Parlament vorliegen
sie ausgiebig die Gelegenheit hatten
sich mit dem Inhalt dieser Gesetze zu
beschäftigen wir dann noch wir dann noch
als Koalition viele Verbesserungen an
diesem Gesetz vorgenommen haben und ich
glaube dass sich die Menschen in diesem
Land vor allem dafür interessieren was
wir mit den 200 30 Milliarden die wir
hier heute beschließen werden denn
eigentlich Unternehmen und ich hätte
mich sehr gefreut wenn sich ihre
Debatten Beiträge auch darauf beziehen
würden wie denn dieses Geld verwendet
wird wie es richtig eingesetzt wird wie
es Schaden von den Menschen abhält die
es Schaden von den Unternehmen in diesem
Land abhält wie wir vielleicht Dinge von
denen wir wissen dass sie noch nicht
optimal sind wie wir die verbessern ich
nenne ihn mal ein Beispiel der haben
erkannt dass es Missbrauchs Potential in
diesem Gesetz gibt wir haben erkannt das
die Möglichkeit gibt hier auch gegen den
Steuerzahler sich zu optimieren das ist
der Grund warum es in diesem Gesetz eine
zusätzliche Verordnung gibt meine
Erwartung an den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister ist da ganz
klar er muss dafür sorgen dass diese
Verordnung jetzt auch sehr schnell kommt
und dass das Missbrauchspotenzial
bestmöglich eingedämmt wird wollen wir
vielleicht darüber reden wie 230
Milliarden die den Menschen in diesem
Land gehört richtig eingesetzt werden
und nicht über die Frage wann Sie eine
E-Mail bekommen haben oder wann Sie eine
E-Mail bekommen haben das ist dermaßen
selbstreferenziell dass es dem Anspruch
des Hohen Hauses hier nicht gerecht wird
meine Damen und Herren
und ich meine das ist der wesentliche
Punkt zum einen wir haben noch eine
ganze Menge zu tun und wir laden die
Opposition dazu ein an diesen Stellen
auch weiter mitzuarbeiten das Thema
Missbrauchspotential ich habe es eben
angesprochen und ich werde auch selbst
ganz persönlich weiterhin auch
öffentlich dafür werben dass wir diese
Lücken schließen denn es sind noch große
Lücken und das zweite ist die Zeit des
künstlich für günstigsten Energie sie
muss bestmöglich genutzt werden erstens
für die dauerhafte Erhöhung des
energieangebots wir müssen eine ehrliche
Kapazitätsplanung vornehmen dazu gehört
für uns für eine Industrienation wie
Deutschland auch die Ausweitung
günstiger CO2-freier Grundlastkraftwerke
der Ausbau der heimischen Gasförderung
und selbstverständlich auch der Ausbau
der freiheitsenergie und natürlich
gehört dazu auch dass wir beim Thema
Effizienz jetzt mal PS machen was ist
denn eigentlich mit den Smart Mietern in
den letzten 10 Jahren geschehen da ist
unter den großen Koalition gar nichts
vorangekommen wir haben große Aufgaben
für das Jahr 2023 die erste Welle der
Attacken aus Russland haben wir
abgeschmettert aber die Deiche müssen
dauerhaft gestärkt werden bei uns im
Norden heißt es nicht der Wind
entscheidet den Kurs sondern das
richtige Setzen der Segel und das wird
für 2023 unsere Aufgabe sein in allen
frohe Weihnachten und herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
Michael Kruse von der FDP dessen
Redezeit sich etwas verlängert hat durch
die beiden Zwischenfragen von Carsten
[Applaus]
Carsten Hilse von der
afd-fraktion und Klaus Ernst von den
Linken Redner jetzt Ralf lenkert
ebenfalls von der Fraktion der Linken
auch in diesen Zeiten müssen Strom und
Gas bezahlbar bleiben deshalb ist ein
preiswertes grundkontingent für Strom
und Gas nach Haushaltsgröße notwendig
bei Strom kostet die Kilowattstunde
maximal 30 bei Gas maximal 18 und wir
brauchen eine monatliche
inflationspauschale von 75 € je Haushalt
plus 50 € je Person im Haushalt vom
Staat bezahlt
das fordert DIE LINKE das wäre ein guter
Weg durch den Winter jetzt hat die Ampel
Einmalzahlung von nur 300 Euro
veranlasst hat eine Preisgrenze von 40
sind bei Strom und 12 sind bei Gas
festgeschrieben aber nur für 80 Prozent
des bisherigen persönlichen Verbrauches
das reicht nicht wer viel verdient viel
Strom und gasverbraucht hat die Mitte
leicht 20% Energie einzusparen und
bekommt dafür dann die Gesamtenergie zum
Festpreis arme Familien dagegen mussten
schon immer Energie sparen und haben
heute mehr denn je nicht das Geld
sparsame Technik zu kaufen die müssen
dann mehr zahlen das ist uns sozial
schamlos nutzen Konzerne und Spekulanten
jede Gelegenheit Preise und Profite
hochzutreiben RWE machte allein im
ersten Halbjahr den zweieinhalbfachen
Gewinn des kompletten Vorjahres Shell
steigere den halbjahresgewinn von 5,5
auf 12 Milliarden Euro über 50
Milliarden Euro sondergewinde fielen in
Deutschland bis heute an diese Gewinne
will die Linke abschöpfen für die
Finanzierung erhilfen für Bürgerinnen
und Bürger für produzierende Unternehmen
für Handwerk für Hochschulen und für
Krankenhäuser aber diese Ampel schöpft
nur kümmerliche 3 Milliarden ab bei 50
Milliarden extra-
Strom gaswärme sind unverzichtbare
Daseinsvorsorge Daseinsvorsorge muss der
Gesellschaft gehören das fordert DIE
LINKE vielen Dank
für weiter Ralf lenkert von den Linken
nächste Rednerinnen ist Ingrid Nestle
von bis 90 die Grünen es geht noch etwa
bis 11 Uhr Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe
Zuschauer
mit dieser Debatte zu den beiden
energiepreisbremsen weiter danach gibt
es zwei namentliche Abstimmungen also
gegen 11 Uhr etwa ist diese Debatte
beendet sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir unterstützen heute mit diesem Gesetz
alle in diesem Land die von den
dramatischen Preissteigerungen von
fossilem Erdgas getroffen sind sei es
direkt oder indirekt durch die
Preissteigerungen bei Strom und Wärme
wir unterstützen alle egal ob Haushalt
ob Unternehmen ob Kommunen weil wir
einen gemeinsamen Ansatz haben bei dem
niemand durch die Lücke fällt durch die
Ritze zu definieren was ist das
Unternehmen im Hinterzimmer der Wohnung
wir unterstützen alle und das ist gut so
das Geld
das Geld kommt auch bei den Menschen an
ohne dass sie einen Antrag stellen
müssen ohne ein einziges Formular an
auszufüllen kommt diese substanzielle
und entscheidende Hilfe bei dem Menschen
an und auch das ist gut so
wichtig ist auch dass die Menschen nicht
nur direkt Geld bekommen mit diesem
Gesetz sondern wenn sie Energie sparen
und da danke ich auch der Union dir das
auch angesprochen hat ja wir müssen
unbedingt weiter Energie sparen wir
bleiben auch als Koalition weiter dran
nach vielen Maßnahmen wir schon für
Energieeffizienz auf den Weg gebracht
haben auch da weiter mit dabei zu sein
und alle die in diesem Winter Energie
sparen und gerade jetzt wo es so kalt
wird ja sieht man wieder wie der
Gasverbrauch hoch geht wie wichtig ist
dass wir alle mitziehen alle die haben
hinterher noch mal richtig mehr Geld im
Geldbeutel denn jede Kilowattstunde Gas
die Sie einsparen jede Kilowattstunde
Strom wie Sie einsparen da haben sie die
volle Ersparnis in Ihrem Geldbeutel drin
auch das bekommen wir hin und auch das
ist sehr gut so
wichtig wichtig ist mir aber auch dass
wir mit diesem Gesetz nicht einfach nur
sagen ja hier Geld ach und dann feiern
wir mal Weihnachten dann gucken wir mal
was passiert und oh vielleicht kommt das
nächste Problem sondern mit diesem
Gesetz sogar auch schon weiter denken
denn es muss auch immer darum gehen die
Ursache von diesem ganzen Schlamassel
die Abhängigkeit von den dramatisch
teuren fossilen Energien zu beseitigen
den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
voranzubringen und auch das auch das
Fassen in diesem Gesetz schon an und ja
es war nicht ganz einfach in der
Koalition aber es ist gelungen wir
werden den Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien für die nächste Ausschreibung
entscheidend mit Strom versorgen weil
nämlich die Obergrenze in den
Ausschreibungen die zu niedrig ist ja
weil auch dort Inflation herrscht weil
eben auch bei den Anlagen Infektionen
hat weil auch bei den Zinsen Inflation
herrscht weil plötzlich der Auswahl
Erneuerbaren zu ihr liegen oder zum
Stocken zu kommen rote auch diesen Punkt
haben wir jetzt schon angegangen denn
wir können nicht auf Dauer immer mal
wieder 200 Milliarden nehmen und
entlassen nein wir müssen die Ursache
beseitigen und wir zeigen dass die Ampel
auch das und auch in diesem Gesetz schon
angeht
und auch das Kollege jung ist natürlich
die Antwort auf den Punkt den sie
inhaltlich zurecht aufgeworfen haben ich
teile Ihre Analyse dass wir dringend
bezahlbare Energie für die Industrie
besorgen müssen aber da ist doch nicht
der Punkt ob Robert Habeck sowieso
beinhart verhandelt in Brüssel ja noch
ein Prozentpunkt mehrere ausschlägt bei
den Punkten die Sie gerade kritisiert
haben der entscheidende Punkt ist doch
warum mir die letzten 10 Jahre so wenig
erneuerbare ausgebaut haben und dass wir
jetzt dazu hinbekommen müssen dass wir
die endlich haben und da wünsche ich mir
sehr und da freue ich mich sehr wenn wir
alle gemeinsam zusammenarbeiten denn es
ist wirklich ernst danke schön
Ingrid Nestle von den Bündnisgrünen mit
ihrem Debattenbeitrag sie Sprecherin für
Klimaschutz und Energie
fachsprecher für Energiepolitik in
Unionsfraktion ist mal Helferich und der
erhält jetzt das Wort
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen strompreisbremse gaspreisbremse
die Titel der Gesetze über die wir heute
reden drücken das genaue Gegenteil
dessen aus was sie mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit bewirken werden
nämlich den Strom und Gaspreis künstlich
hochzuhalten viel treffender wäre es das
heutige Gesetzespaket wie die FAZ das
große Geld verbrennen zu bezeichnen und
das ist es auch
warum die sogenannte Preisbremse
beinhaltet ein Mechanismus der die
Preise für Strom und Gas künstlich
hochhält eine Art Booster also ein
Beispiel Strom erklärt hier Deckel der
Staat für 80 Prozent des
vorjahresverbrauchs die Strompreise auf
40 Cent je Kilowattstunde alles was
darüber liegt übernimmt der Staat so
weit so gut
vollkommen schräg ist allerdings ihr
Belohnungssystem Herr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister das einen
Anreiz zum Energiesparen setzen soll
hätten sie mal lieber den 50er
rausgerückt es wäre besser gewesen
ihr Anreizsystem sie vereinsparungen
über 20 Prozent hinausgehen eine
Gutschrift zum aktuellen Vertragspreis
vor je höher der Tarif desto größer die
Entlastung Versorger und Kunden
profitieren der Staat bezahlt an eine
Pflicht den Preis zu senken wenn es die
Marktlage gebietet hat die Ampel nicht
gedacht
auch bei einem weiteren Blick in ihr
Gesetz wird deutlich die Ampel hat
grundlegende Marktprinzipien immer noch
nicht verstanden sie Deckel nämlich nur
die Preise ohne dass Angebot auszuweiten
lassen Sie mich Ihnen das einfach noch
mal ganz simpel erklären wenn alle
Bundesländer so weit wären wie das
unionsgeführte Schleswig-Holstein beim
Ausbau der Windkraft hätten wir mehr
Strom zur Verfügung und der Preis würde
sinken wenn das Rot
wenn das rot-grüne hamburg den Betrieb
des hochmodernen Kohlekraftwerks in
Moorburg nicht jahrelang torpediert
hätte könnte es heute vermutlich noch
Strom produzieren und der Preis würde
sinken wenn die Ampel die Laufzeiten
unserer Atomkraftwerke in der Krise bis
2024 verlängert hätte gäbe es mehr Strom
und der Preis würde sinken und anstatt
auf anstatt auf mehr gesicherten
Biostrom zu setzen verunsichern sie
wochenlang eine ganze Branche mit
maßlosen abschöpfungsplänen das ist rot
grün gelbe verknappungspolitik
oder auch es mit den Worten unserer
Vizepräsidentin Göring-Eckardt zu sagen
das ist Wohlstand des weniger und ich
profitiere prophezeit in eines und
danach kommt nur noch Wohlstand für
weniger
meine Damen und Herren Kritik ist leider
auch notwendig an der geplanten
Entlastung für heizölpellets und
flüssiggaskunden die Union hat diese
seit Monaten eingefordert und es ist
immer noch nicht klar wann diese für
Privathaushalte kommt und dann will die
Ampel auch noch 13,5 Millionen Haushalte
in ihrer Logik Härtefälle
zur Abgabe einer eidesstattlichen
Erklärung zu ihrer brennstoffrechnung
nötigen damit setzen sie unsere Bürger
auch noch dem Risiko aus dass sie sich
unbeabsichtigt einer falschen
Versicherung an Eides stadtstrafe machen
es drohen im schlimmsten
fallfreiheitsstrafen bis zu drei Jahren
oder Geldstrafe
da müssen Menschen auf sich nehmen um
nicht zu frieren
und für unsere kleinen und mittleren
Betriebe ist immer noch unklar wer wie
viel wann was bekommt
ihm fehlt nicht nur der wirtschaftliche
Verstand sondern auch das Herz für
unseren Mittelstand
und bei Weihnachten eine Zeit der
Besinnung und des in sich Gehens ist
habe ich in der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister etwas
Weihnachtsgebäck aus einer
mittelständischen Familienbäckerei
mitgebracht in diesem Sinne wünsche ich
Ihnen allen besinnliche Weihnachten
ja nächster Redner ist Karl Lauterbach
der Bundesgesundheitsminister da fragt
man sich im ersten Moment bei diesem
Thema hat er sich möglicherweise im
Parlament verlaufen nein er ist auch
zuständig für energiepreisbremsen denn
zusätzlich zu diesen energiepreisbremsen
soll es ein Hilfsprogramm soll es ein
Hilfsprogramm geben der Bundesregierung
über 8 Milliarden Euro zur Dämpfung der
Energiekosten der Energiepreis Explosion
für Krankenhäuser und Pflegeheime
nächster Redner Karl Lauterbach
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben heute
eine wichtige auch eine zum Teil
technische Debatte aber ich möchte noch
einmal auf den Hintergrund dieser
Debatte zuerst zu sprechen kommen der
Hintergrund dieser Debatte ist leicht zu
beschreiben Gas Strom Energie wird
teurer und wir nehmen das hin wir werden
uns einschränken wir werden damit
klarkommen aber dass Signal was wir
heute senden und das bitte ich Sie auch
zu beachten Sie können es nach Moskau
direkt senden wir lassen uns nicht
erpressen wir lassen uns nicht der
pressen und es um die Verteidigung der
Menschenrechte geht dann werden wir uns
nicht durch die Gaspreise und die
Strompreise erpressen lassen wir stehen
jetzt zusammen und verteidigen die
Demokratie und die Menschenrechte
und ich möchte bei dieser Gelegenheit
auch noch einmal ausdrücklich dem
Kollegen Robert Habeck danken dieses
Paket hinzubekommen ein 200 Milliarden
Paket technisch sehr aufwendig für alle
Bereiche der Wirtschaft ausgreifend die
Bürger schützend umgesetzt in einer Art
und Weise dass eben nicht die Gaspreise
durch die Decke gehen dass wir nicht
durch die Unternehmen der pressbar sind
und dass das Geld auch überall im Land
ankommt das ist keine Kleinigkeit das
Verfahren ist durch die Beratung im
Bundestag besser geworden dafür bedanke
ich mich auch auch wir haben sehr viele
Änderungsanträge spät eingebracht aber
den Grundkonzeption ist vom Kollegen
Harbeck hier in einer Art und Weise
eingebracht worden wo wir sagen können
darauf können wir stolz sein das ist ein
Handwerk was erst einmal geleistet
werden muss das lässt sich leicht wenn
man noch nie ein Gesetz verantworten
muss sondern wahrscheinlich niemals tun
wird so wie es sich hier gestartet lässt
sich vielleicht sagen aber Kritik in der
Sache ist richtig aber im Grundkurs ist
dieses Gesetz die Grundlage dafür dass
er durch diese Krise hindurchkommt und
zum Schluss stärker sein werden weil es
ist ein Gesetz was gleichzeitig vorsieht
dass der Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien nicht entschleunigt wird wie
sehr es sich wünschen würden und auch
hier sondern es wird beschleunigt wir
werden stärker aus dieser Krise
herauskommen was wir in die Krise
hineingegangen sind wir werden
unabhängiger sein werden mehr
erneuerbare Energien haben wir werden
durchkommen und lassen sich ganz lauter
machen gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
oder Bemerkung aus der Fraktion DIE
LINKE von Frau lütsch
ich würde um Verständnis bitten bei
dieser Gelegenheit nein
ich möchte auf den zentralen Teil auch
zu sprechen kommen der unsere der unsere
krankenhausarbeiter betrifft die
Krankenhäuser und die Praxen aber auch
die Pflegeeinrichtungen kämpfen
besonders mit der Erhöhung dieser Phase
was wir hier gemacht haben nur dass das
verstanden wird wir haben hier
tatsächlich eine Regelung gefunden die
die Mehrkosten für Energie Gas und Strom
zu 100% Ausgleich wir gehen hier über
den Wirkmechanismus der gaspreisbremse
und der strompreisbremse hinaus wo ja
70% erstattet werden und bei den
Konsumenten 80%, und der Staaten hier
100%, sondern der Grundgedanke ist der
wenn wir aus dieser Krise herauskommen
dann werden wir sehen dass nicht ein
einziges Krankenhaus ist nicht deine
einzige Rehaklinik auf der Grundlage
höherer Strom und Gaspreise aus dem
Markt ausschalten das ist eine
großartige Leistung das ist der Beginn
einer
Ökonomisierung unseres
Gesundheitssystems weil wir machen es
eben hier nicht so dass diejenigen die
Gewinne machen sich die höheren
Gaspreise lassen können und diejenigen
die Rücklagen haben sich die höheren
Strompreise lassen können sondern die
gleichen es aus für jeden wir nehmen
jeden mit das ist der Anspruch den wir
hier haben daher darf ich mich ganz
herzlich dafür bedanken auch für die
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit in dieser
Hinsicht auch ausdrücklich bei den
Kollegen von der Union die hier
mitgezogen haben wir haben zum Schluss
auch noch die Apotheker als
impfstellenmaterial gebracht auf die
letzte Sekunde das ist sinnvoll das zu
machen wir müssen mehr impfen auch gegen
die Grippe und wir haben es geschafft
das Leben Verordnung weitergeht so mit
einem gutes Gesetz ich bitte um ihre
Zustimmung wir lassen uns durch die
russische
Menschenrechtsverletzung von Putin nicht
erpressen wir gehen gestärkt gemeinsam
aus dieser Krise heraus
ja wie angekündigt hat Karl Lauterbach
tatsächlich zu den Krankenhäusern
Pflegeeinrichtungen gesprochen im ersten
Teil der Rede und jetzt zum Schluss
allerdings Dinge gesagt die man
eigentlich eher von Christian Lindner
oder Robert Habeck erwartet hätte beide
werden in dieser laufenden Debatte
allerdings das Wort nicht ergreifen weil
ihre Zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen
wurde jetzt eine Kurzintervention von
Gesine lütsch von der Fraktion DIE LINKE
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr
Minister lauterbach
sie hat Plenardebatte von der
Regierungsbank ausgewittert und haben
falsch Behauptung aufgestellt dazu hätte
ich sie gern gefragt sie haben in Ihrem
Tweet behauptet Klaus Ernst und die
Linke beklatschen ein Lob auf russisches
Öl das ist falsch Klaus Ernst hat die
Situation geschrieben nämlich dass der
Wohlstand der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
Jahre lang Jahrzehnte lang darauf geruht
hat dass billiges Gas billiger Strom
billiges Öl exportiert wurde und zwar in
einseitiger Abhängigkeit von Russland er
hat das nicht gelogen er hat diese
Situation beschrieben und der wohl
weiterhin darauf dass wir eben teure
Technologien exportieren konnten
und der Zwischenruf mit dem Porsche ist
völlig dämlich ich will darauf hinweisen
Herr Lauterbach dass sie dass sie seit
2005 seit 2005 Mitglied des Bundestages
sind und
ich würde auch meine eigene Fraktion
bitten jetzt nicht zu streiten ich will
auf jeden Fall dass Sie Herr Lauterbach
seit 2005 Mitglied des Bundestages sind
und damit etliche große Koalition
mitgetragen haben und dass sie damit mit
verantwortlich sind für die Organisation
dieser einseitigen Abhängigkeit von
Russland stehen sie zu ihrer
Verantwortung und beschimpfen sie nicht
von der Regierungsbank aus per Twitter
was sowieso eine Unsinn ist meine
Kollegen vielen Dank
da sagt noch mal jemand Debatten über
die energiepreisbremsen sein ohne
Unterhaltungswert das war die
Kurzintervention von xine Lodge jetzt
die Erwiderung von Karl Lauterbach
sondern von Gas und zum zweiten ich habe
noch nicht gesagt also
dass ich die gleichsetze sondern ich
habe darauf hingewiesen dass der Kollege
Ernst ausgedrückt hat dass wir dankbar
sein sollen dass wir diese Abhängigkeit
gehabt haben ja gesagt wir sollen
dankbar sein Kollege hat gesagt wir
sollen der Kollege hat übrigens in der
Kollege hat übrigens mit Blickkontakt
ausgerichtet zu den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der grünen Partei gesagt
mit Blick in die Richtung der Grünen er
hat gesagt dass wir dankbar sein sollen
dass wir von diesem Gast profitieren
dürfen das bedeutet wir sollen dankbar
sein für eine Politik die uns eine
Abhängigkeit gebracht hat von der
derzeit alle sagen können wir leiden
darunter und das das somit wenn Sie wenn
Sie jetzt wenn sie jetzt abonnieren wenn
sie jetzt monieren dass ich sage es sei
ein Lob gewesen oder ein dank gewesen
dann dann korrigiere ich das aber ich
finde ehrlich gesagt den dank genauso
problematisch wie das Lob wenn sie es
gelobt hätten
für alle die nicht auf Zwitter unterwegs
sind müssen wir das jetzt so hinnehmen
belassen es dabei und
Bernd Plenarsitzung das würde uns allen
sehr entgegenkommen das ist die Meinung
von Bärbel Bars das hier im Plenarsaal
auszuhandelt vor laufenden Mikrofon und
Fernsehkameras und nicht über Twitter
auf diesem Social Media Kanal sind ja
auch nicht alle unterwegs nächster
Redner Konrad Stockmeyer von der FDP
Damen und Herren als Liberaler
energiepolitiker bin ich dezidiert der
Meinung dass auch der Energiemarkt
funktionieren kann wie ein Markt
eigentlich funktionieren sollte nämlich
als rechtssicherer und wettbewerblicher
Rahmen in dem sich Innovation in dem
sich auch das Gewinnstreben und in dem
sich Investitionen so entfalten dass am
besten das am Ende das bestmögliche
dabei rauskommt nämlich eine
preisgünstige sichere Energieversorgung
für Privathaushalte für Betriebe in
diesem Land und auch für Krankenhäuser
warum hebe ich heute als Liberale
energiepolitiker also meine Hand für
einen Werkzeugkasten von dem ich der
festen Überzeugung bin dass er so
schnell wie möglich wieder im Keller
verschwinden sollte warum weil es in
Zeiten des energiekrieges darum gehen
muss Schaden von diesem Land abzuwenden
warum hebe ich heute meine Hand für
Instrumente wie Erlös abschöpfungen und
preisbremsen die nun dezidiert auf einem
funktionierenden Markt nicht zum Einsatz
kommen sollten wenn er den funktionieren
würde
warum weil es darum geht in diesen
Zeiten den Energiemarkt zu stabilisieren
preislich das funktioniert übrigens auch
schon weil es darum geht Schäden von
diesem Land abzuwenden und übrigens auch
Scherben einer Energiepolitik
staatlichen Versagens in diesem Lande
aufzukehren dass jahrelang das jahrelang
angerichtet worden ist weil wir einen
Fehler gemacht haben den wir nie wieder
machen dürfen uns nämlich einseitig in
die Abhängigkeit eines mörderischen
Regimes zu begegnen einseitig in die
Abhängigkeit von feindender Freiheit das
darf uns nie wieder passieren und das
seit und das seid Ausbruch des Krieges
auch aus diesem Hause heraus immer
wieder von der rechten Seite und ich
will fernleiben Ralf von Teilen der
linken Seite nicht komplett Liebesgrüße
nach Moskau geschickt werden das ist
einigermaßen unerträglich
es muss also darum gehen mit diesen
Maßnahmen heute eine Brücke zu bauen in
eine sichere und bezahlbare
Energieversorgung der Zukunft die sich
dadurch auszeichnen sollte dass sie
übrigens nicht nur in einem deutschen
sondern in einem europäischen Sinne so
dezentral wie möglich organisiert ist
sowohl in der Produzenten als auch in
der Eigentümerstruktur dass sie flexibel
ist und jawohl dass sie für privates
Kapital auch attraktive Ertragschancen
bietet und dass sie sich technologisch
vielfältig gestaltet es ist überhaupt
keine Zeit dafür dabei zu verlieren
diese Aufgabe anzupacken wir als Freie
Demokraten werden da ganz konstruktiv
mitwirken danke für die Aufmerksamkeit
Konrad Stockmeier von der FDP ist schon
der zweite FDP-Abgeordnete der sozusagen
im selbstbesichtigungsmodus hier im
Bundestag Auftritt dass die
energiepreisbremsen doch das
ordnungspolitische Modell der FDP Arcen
nächster Redner Andreas Mehltretter von
der SPD
meine Damen und Herren die preisbremsen
kommen das was wir versprochen haben das
setzen wir heute um wir lassen niemanden
allein wir schützen viele Betriebe
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor den Kosten
die sie nicht tragen können und wir
geben damit die richtige jetzt
kurzfristig notwendige Antwort auf die
Energiekrise
wir geben aber auch die Antwort die
mittel und langfristig notwendig ist die
Zukunft unserer Energieversorgung muss
erneuerbar sein Strom und Wärme aus
Sonne Wind Wasser und Biomasse senken
schon heute die Preise sie machen uns
unabhängig von Rohstoffimporten der
Schlüssel für zukünftig sichere und
bezahlbare Energie sind gute
Investitionsbedingungen für Wind und
Solaranlagen
deswegen geben wir der Bundesnetzagentur
bei der Erneuerbaren Förderung den
Spielraum den sie braucht um auf die
gestiegenen Kosten zu reagieren Wind und
Solar bleiben die günstigsten
Stromerzeuger aber auch dort macht sich
die Inflation bemerkbar die
Bundesnetzagentur kann jetzt die
Ausschreibungen so gestalten dass wir
unsere ausbaummengen die wir uns
vorgenommen haben auch erreichen können
das ist ein extrem wichtiger Schritt für
die erneuerbaren Energien und ein extrem
wichtiger Schritt für eine sichere und
preiswerte Energieversorgung meine Damen
und Herren
wir stellen auch sicher dass die
sinnvolle und notwendige Abschöpfung von
überschusserlösen den Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren eben nicht bremst es ist
richtig überschusserlöse wegen der
Energie wegen der Energiekrise entstehen
auch bei erneuerbaren Energien
abzuschöpfen das gehört zur gerechten
Finanzierung der Preis Bremsen zum
Beispiel bei Biogasanlagen aber war der
sogenannte Sicherheitszuschlag zu
niedrig für einen kostendeckenden
Betrieb wir haben diesen
Sicherheitszuschlag deswegen auf 19
erhöht damit ist gewährleistet dass die
Biogasanlagen auch weiterhin mit voller
Kraft Strom produzieren
meine Damen und Herren die preisbremsen
wirken schnell das ist es was gerade im
Vordergrund stehen muss wir haben in den
Beratungen aber auch feststellen müssen
dass wir nicht alles sofort lösen können
die Gasversorger wissen zum Beispiel
nicht wie viele Haushalte denn an einem
Anschluss hängen deshalb geht manches
was die Bremsen gerechter machen würde
im Moment nicht es geht noch nicht das
Modell der Preis Bremsen soll aber eben
ein lernendes Modell sein mit dem wir in
Zukunft noch zielgerichteter
unterstützen können deshalb fordern wir
die Bundesregierung auch auf bis zum
Sommer zu prüfen wie Einkommens ärmere
sparsame Haushalte besser entlastet
werden können etwa mit einem
haushaltsbezogenen Basis Kontingent und
die Bundesregierung muss untersuchen wie
mit einer Obergrenze verhindert werden
könnte das reiche Haushalte mit
übermäßig hohem Verbrauch übermäßige
Subventionen bekommen dadurch wollen wir
die gaspreisbremse noch gerechter
meine Damen und Herren es ist bereits
darauf hingewiesen worden ein ebenso
zentraler Punkt für die Gerechtigkeit
ist dass wir auch die nicht alleine
lassen die mit Öl mit Pellets oder mit
Flüssiggas heizen auch wenn solche
Brennstoffe für die Heizung kaufen
musste soll bei einer Belastung die über
dem doppelten liegt des vor diesen
Niveaus eine Entlastung bekommen können
so geht gerechte Politik in der
Energiekrise
meine Damen und Herren die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in unserem Land erwarten dass
wir alles dafür tun dass Energie
bezahlbar bleibt deswegen hat es mich
doch sehr verwundert dass CD und CSU im
Ausschuss die preisbremsen abgelehnt
haben und das heute ja anscheinend
wieder tun wollen das zeigt wo
wirtschaftsverstand und Herz für den
Mittelstand wirklich fehlt Therme
hilfreich
wir stellen heute sicher das Energie
bezahlbar bleibt und mit den ab mit der
Abstimmung wird deutlich wer es mit den
Entlastungen ernst meint wir als Ampel
jedenfalls zeigen wir lassen niemanden
allein
Andreas mildwetter aus dem Wahlkreis
Freising der nächste Regner kommt aus
dem benachbarten Wahlkreis Erding
Ebersberg allerdings nicht von der SPD
sondern von der Unionsfraktion Andreas
Lenz Sprecher für Energie und
Nachhaltigkeit der CSU Landesgruppe
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
am Ende der
Debatte feststellen es ist immer mit
einer gewissen Vorsicht zu genießen wenn
der Bundesgesundheitsminister über
Energiepolitik spricht und
und dieser dieser Fakt wirkt wird auch
ein gewisses Licht auf das Verfahren des
stattfand
ab zunächst einmal ist es doch zu
betonen dass es gut ist grundsätzlich
das Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlastet
werden und wir waren und sind nicht
gegenentlastungen im Gegenteil wir
fordern diese Zeit beginnt dieses Jahres
so und ich kann es ihnen nicht ersparen
sie haben viel Zeit vergeudet die
unsägliche Diskussion der Streit um die
gasumlage die weder umsetzbar noch
verfassungsgemäß war die viel Geld
verschwendet hat ich war neulich bei den
Stadtwerken in Augsburg aus Beispiel
allein diese Stadtwerke mussten 150.000
Euro aufwenden für eine gasumlage die
nie kam hier wurde die Murks und der
Murks ging weiter bei der Gas und
strompreisbremse die zwar fast 400
Seiten die am Morgen des Mittwochs des
gestrigen mittwochs kamen sind kein
Zeichen für Respekt gegenüber dem
Parlament aber auch nicht für ein
Zeichen von Respekt gegenüber den
Betroffenen
zuerst zuerst wollten sie die
Erneuerbaren rückwirkend zum ersten
dritten abschöpfen dann zum 1.9 jetzt
zum ersten 12 das schafft erhebliche
Verunsicherung die derzeitige
Investitions Zurückhaltung bei den
Erneuerbaren geht auch auf ihre Politik
zurück sehr geehrte Damen und Herren und
wenn ich jetzt sehe dass PP ist dass
letzten Endes quasi ja
Vertragsverhältnisse ausgebremst werden
und dadurch Innovationen ausgebremst
werden bei den Erneuerbaren Stichwort
Wunsiedel wasserstoffregion dann ist es
auch ihr Verantwortung dass diese
Projekte nicht stattfinden ebenso haben
sie die Branche der Bioenergie
verunsichert ja in Existenz
Existenzängste versetzt sehr Höhen zwar
jetzt in Sicherheitszuschlag
altholzanlagen haben aber nach wie vor
große Probleme als Beispiel Steinkohle
wird nicht abgeschafft nachhaltige
Bioenergie schon das muss man sich mal
vorstellen klüger wäre es die Bioenergie
ganz aus der Abschöpfung auszunehmen wie
wir das entsprechend fordern
erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage von Frau
lessner von Bündnis 90 die Grünen nein
es ist wichtig Inhaber von Holzpellet
Heizungen von Heizöl von
flüssiggasheizungen ebenfalls zu
entlasten auch das fordern wir seit
Beginn der Debatte ob der vor in Höhe
von 1,8 Milliarden Euro aber ausreicht
das ist mir das ist mehr als fraglich
sorgen sie für eine entsprechende
Finanzierung der Hilfen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren
noch noch ist übrigens überhaupt nicht
sicher ob das Geld ob die Hilfen auch
tatsächlich bei den Unternehmen ankommen
noch ist nicht sicher ob damit
Arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben laut die
sind die Hilfen vielfach überhaupt nicht
anwendbares liegt am Beihilferecht aber
nicht nur das liegt auch an der
Komplexität die Anwendung setzen Sie
sich dafür ein dass die Beihilfe dass
das Beihilferecht ermöglicht und nicht
verhindert dass die Industrie dass der
Standard Deutschland einen Zukunft eine
Zukunft hat sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
und es hieß ja vorher das gewisse Dinge
corona-fälle in 2021 das hochwasserfälle
berücksichtigt werden können in Gesetz
steht dazu übrigens noch gar nichts auch
die Besteuerung steht nicht im Gesetz
sondern nur in einem
Entschließungsantrag und es ist eben so
dass die gerechtigkeitsdefizite noch
nach wie vor vorhanden sind und
gesetzlich nicht gelöst sind am besten
gegen hohe Preise ist ein hohes Angebot
das geht auch und gerade bei der Energie
durch den Ausstieg aus der Kernkraft zum
15 April erreichen Sie genau das
Gegenteil ihre Politik trägt dazu bei
dass im Moment
rekordmengen von Gas verstromt werden es
wurde noch nie so viel Gas verstrom wie
im Moment 20% des Stroms kommen aus
Gaskraftwerken das muss man sich auch
mal vorstellen und letzten Endes
brauchen wir natürlich einen massiven
aus bei der Erneuerbaren aber immer auch
ein Backup durch im Moment eben
konventionelle Kraftwerke das ist die
Verantwortung um entsprechenden
Energiesicherheit zu geben herzlichen
Dank
wir haben sicherlich gerade alle
mitbekommen gesehen und gehört im
Präsidium hat gewechselt
von der ebenfalls von der SPD hat jetzt
Bärbel Bars als Präsidentin als
amtierende Präsidentin der laufenden
Sitzung abgelöst die voraussichtlich
letzte Rednerin dieser Debatte über die
energiepreisbremsen vor der Abstimmung
ist Zander Martens von der SPD
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Parteien Liebe
Mieterinnen und Mieter Deutschland ist
das Niederland Nummer 1 in der EU
nirgendwo ist die Eigentumsquote
niedriger mehr als die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung kann sich wohl Eigentum
nicht leisten und lebt hierzulande zu
mieten auch Düsseldorf mein Wahlkreis
ist eine Mieter statt dort leben sogar
80 Prozent zu mieten
und Mieter sind in unserem Land also die
übergroße Mehrheit an MieterInnen
sollten wir daher in der Politik immer
denken das Recht auf Wohnraum achten die
Mieten bezahlbar halten und sie in
Krisenzeiten entlasten
damit MieterInnen die nicht selbst mit
ihrem Energieversorger direkt sondern
über den Vermieter abrechnen zum
Beispiel in zentral beheizten Häusern
damit sie nicht schlechter behandelt
werden als alle anderen waren für uns
jetzt nicht nur wegen Weihnachten drei
Wünsche besonders wichtig und für die
haben wir gekämpft erstens die
MieterInnen werden rückwirkend auch für
Januar und Februar entlastet und die
Weitergabe die Weitergabe der
Entlastungen an die MieterInnen
betreffen nicht nur die die mit Gas und
Fernwärme heizen sondern auch alle die
mit Strom heizen auch mit Wärmepumpe
oder Nachtspeicherheizung der
Entlastungen kommen also allen
MieterInnen zugute alles andere wäre
auch zutiefst ungerecht gewesen
zweitens muss der Vermieter die
Betriebskosten Vorauszahlung
unverzüglich anpassen nicht erst nach
der Betriebskostenabrechnung für 2023
die schlimmstenfalls erst Ende 24 kommt
fast erfährter sich beeilt um die
turnusmäßige Jahresabrechnung für dieses
Jahr bis zum ersten April 23
fertiggestellt kann die Anpassung der
Betriebskosten Vorauszahlung gemeinsam
mit der Jahresabrechnung erfolgen
spätestens dann muss dabei die
Betriebskosten Vorauszahlung auf jeden
Fall angepasst sein
drittens brauchen die MieterInnen nicht
selbst aktiv zu werden sie müssen die
Entlastungen nicht selbst errechnen und
dem Vermieter Anzeigen das war uns
wichtig denn wir wissen doch genau das
gerade auf dem heutigen Wohnungsmarkt
Mieter und Vermieter nicht auf Augenhöhe
sind Mieter sind allzu oft nur heilfroh
überhaupt eine Bleibe gefunden zu haben
und sogar noch eine bezahlbare kaum
einen Mieter legt sich doch heute
freiwillig mit dem Vermieter an deshalb
war also eine klare Verpflichtung der
Vermieter für uns ein politisches muss
wenn wir wollen dass die Entlastungen
bei den MieterInnen tatsächlich ankommen
und das wollen wir
bei allen Kompromissen bei allen
Kompromissen die unter drei
Koalitionspartnern notwendig sind allein
schon wegen dieser drei Wünsche die wir
den MieterInnen jetzt erfüllen können
wir mit gutem Gewissen sagen wir haben
dafür gesorgt dass MieterInnen gerade
die mit kleinem oder mittlerem Einkommen
im mieterland Deutschland schnell direkt
und unkompliziert bei Gas Wärme und
Stromkreisen entlastet werden frohe
Festtage
soweit Zander Martens von der SPD und
jetzt kommt es zur Verabschiedung dieses
Gesetzes mit entschließungs- und
Änderungsanträgen mir liegt nach unserer
Geschäftsordnung Paragraph 31 eine
Erklärung vor und wir kommen zur
Abstimmung über den von den Fraktionen
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP
eingebrachten Gesetzentwurf zur
Einführung von Preis Bremsen für
leitungsgebundenes Erdgas und Wärme und
Veränderung sonstiger Vorschriften der
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
könnte die Regierungsbank auch ein wenig
zuhören der Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie empfiehlt unter Buchstabe a
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache 49/11 den Gesetzentwurf der
Fraktionen SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP auf Drucksache 4683 in der
ausschussfassung anzunehmen die Fraktion
der AFD hat beantragt über den
Gesetzentwurf in der ausschussfassung
getrennt abzustimmen und zwar zum einen
über Artikel 9 bis Artikel 13 und
Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4 des
Gesetzentwurfs in der ausschussfassung
dazu gehören die Änderung des fünften
Buches Sozialgesetzbuch
desinfektionsschutzgesetzes des
apothekengesetzes und der
Apothekenbetriebsordnung und zum anderen
über den Gesetzentwurf im übrigen
ich rufe zunächst auf die Artikel 9 bis
Artikel 13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4
ich bitte nun diejenigen die Artikel 9
bis Artikel 13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3
und 4 das ist Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung zustimmen wollen um das
Anzeichen
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die grün und
FDP wer stimmt dagegen das ist die
cdu/csu und die AFD wer enthält sich das
ist DIE LINKE damit sind Artikel 9 bis
Artikel 13 und Artikel 15 Absatz 3 und 4
angenommen ich rufe nun auf die übrigen
Teile des Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung wer möchte den übrigen
Teilen des Gesetzentwurfs in der
ausschussfassung zustimmen
das ist wieder die SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen und FDP wer stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu wer enthält sich die linke und
die AFD damit ist sind alle Teile des
Gesetzentwurfs in zweiter Beratung
angenommen hier geht es jetzt um die
gaspreisbremse die damit angenommen
worden ist in gesetzesformen die
Fraktion SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und
FDP haben namentliche Abstimmung
verlangt
unmittelbar nach Eröffnung der
namentlichen Schlussabstimmung stimmen
wir noch über eine Entschließung des
Ausschusses für Klimaschutz und Energie
sowie über den Entschließungsantrag der
Fraktion der CDU CSU ab
deswegen bitte ich die Abgeordneten im
Saal noch hier zu bleiben die Abstimmung
erfolgt wie wir es ja kennen in der
westlobby sie haben zur Abgabe ihre
Korrektur durch mich die Abstimmung
findet natürlich namentlich statt jetzt
war ja nur eine Abstimmung darüber in
welcher Form die einzelnen Paragraphen
Abschnitte dieses Gesetzes abgestimmt
werden sollen die namentliche Abstimmung
wird natürlich erst das Ergebnis bringen
es besteht aber kein Zweifel daran dass
ich die Ampelkoalition bei
gaspreisbremse und später dann bei der
strompreisbremse durchsetzt
bevorstehende Ende wird auch wieder
bekannt gegeben
so unter Buchstabe b seiner
Beschlussempfehlung auf Drucksache 49/11
empfiehlt der Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie eine Entschließung
anzunehmen wer stimmt für diese
Beschlussempfehlung das ist DIE LINKE
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP wer
stimmt dagegen
cdu/csu und AFD Enthaltungen keine die
Beschlussempfehlung ist angenommen wir
kommen zur Abstimmung über den
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion der
CDU CSU auf Drucksache 49 13 wer stimmt
dafür
das ist die cdu/csu wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die SPD Bündnis 90 die Gründe
und FDP wer enthält sich die linke und
die AFD der Entschließungsantrag ist
abgelehnt dieser Entschließungsantrag
der
cocsu-bundestagsfraktion bezog sich auf
die Gaspreise
jetzt folgenden Zusatzpunkt 3
und so rufe ich auch schon auf den
Zusatzpunkt 3 Beratung der
Beschlussempfehlung des Auswärtigen
Ausschusses zu dem Antrag der Fraktion
der cdu/csu mit dem Titel iranische
Protestbewegung entschlossen
Unterstützung unterstützen
Entschuldigung den Testfall einer
frauenorientierten Außenpolitik zum
Erfolg machen für die Aussprache wurde
eine Dauer von 68 Minuten noch mal jetzt
zur Erklärung gerade läuft parallel
jetzt zu dieser
Aussprache über die iranische
Protestbewegung die namentliche
Abstimmung zur gaspreisbremse und danach
folgt dann auch noch folgen auch noch
Anträge Entschließungsanträge und die
namentliche Abstimmung der
Bundestagsabgeordneten zur
strompreisbremse das läuft alles
parallel fortlaufend
liebe Kollegin lamiacador eidamösus hat
es gesagt der iranische prozessbewegung
frauenorientierte Außenpolitik ein
Antrag der Unionsfraktion erste Rednerin
lamiacador von den Bündnisgrünen sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren zunächst einmal
herzlichen Glückwunsch an unserem
bundesaußenministerin alles Gute
wir sehen hier ein Beispiel also da bin
ich also es geht um den Antrag der
cdu/csu zu Protestbewegung entschlossen
unterstützen so lautet der Antrag und
ich finde wir sehen hier ein Beispiel
für die Folgen Ideologie getriebener und
unüberlegter Wortklauberei wie der
Teufel das Weihwasser Schollen sie den
Begriff feministische Außenpolitik nicht
gelten zu lassen sprechen Sie lieber die
Künzel von frauenorientierter aus dem
Politik weiterführt leider führte sie
das genau in eine völlig falsche
Richtung das fängt schon mit dem Titel
ihres Antrags an im Text erklären Sie es
bedürfe einer konkreten Implementierung
einer echten Frauen orientierten
Außenpolitik welche die Verbesserung der
Lage der Frauen konkret in den Blick
nimmt nein es geht im Iran um sehr sehr
viel mehr die Bundesregierung und
insbesondere die bundesaußenministerin
Annalena Werbung hat das sehr genau
verstanden die Proteste sind
feministisch und werden eben nicht von
Frauen für Frauen allein durchgeführt
das belegen die vielen männlichen
Demonstranten die seit nunmehr drei
Monaten auf die Straße gehen und auf
tragischste Weise Ihr Leben riskiere
denn neben der Gleichberechtigung von
Frauen geht es um nichts weniger als den
Protest gegen das Unrechtsregime der
mullas mit ihren unrechtsapparat im
Ganzen
feministische Außenpolitik richtet sich
nicht allein von Frauen auf Frauen das
sagte ich ja bereits es geht auch um
einen emanzipatorischen und
protektionistischen Gesamtansatz im
Hinblick auf marginalisierte Gruppen
feministische Außenpolitik man zu
Einhaltung von Menschenrechten gerade
und insbesondere bei Kindern bei
Menschen mit körperlicher
Beeinträchtigung bei Verfolgung von Herd
aufgrund von Herkunft sexuelle
Orientierung Hautfarbe oder Religion das
haben sehr früh auch Männer im Iran
erkannt und sich solidarisch und mutig
an die Seite der DemonstrantInnen
gestellt diese Verständnis
diesen Verständnis vom feministische
Außenpolitik liegt ein großes
friedenspotenzial zugrunde dass wir die
internationale Diplomatie unablässig ist
meine Damen und Herren mit Bestürzung
haben wir alle die barbarischen
Hinrichtungen von massenhycardi und
Majid durch den Strang genommen
aufgenommen die beiden jungen Männer
haben für einen Iran frei von
Repressionen und Unterdrückung
demonstriert und wurden dafür qualvoll
gehängt was für uns die unvorstellbar
ist ist dort seit Jahren Realität sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren statt
Reformschritte zu gehen halten die
islamistischen Machthaber an ihrer
brutalen Unterdrückungspolitik fest und
ich hoffe inständig dass die Rechnung
der Monats nicht aufgeht die mutigen
Iraner und Iraner gehen bis Datum
weiterhin auf die Straße und dazu
brauchen Sie unser aller Unterstützung
wir meinen es wir meinen es ernst mit
der feministischen Außenpolitik
gegenüber dem Iran vor allem das
Auswärtige Amt war im Duo mit Frankreich
der treibende Motor für die eu-sanktion
gegenüber diesen islamistischen Regime
im menschenrechtsrate Vereinten Nationen
in Genf hat unsere Außenministerin
erfolgreich eine Resolution erwirkt die
die Gewalt gegen Demonstranten und
Demonstranten im Iran verurteilt und
diese durch unabhängige ohne Experte und
Experten dokumentieren sollen wir tun
was in unserer recht und politischen
Macht steht sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren zum Abschluss möchte ich noch
einmal den Blick behalten die mutigen
Demonstranten und Demonstranten im Iran
sind Vorbild für Frauen und Mädchen in
der gesamten Region in Syrien in
Afghanistan gehen die Frauen auf die
Straßen das Video nur kaum zu Kenntnis
genommen als Berichterstatterin für den
Nano Mittleren Osten für meine Fraktion
die selbst syrische Wurzeln hat möchte
ich danke sagen für diesen großen Mut
danke
dass Frauen und Männer in der Region
danke dass Frauen und Männer eben in der
Region sich zusammen gegen das Unrecht
auflehnen und Freiheit fordern und dann
kann unsere Außenministerin Anna-Lena
Werbung die diesen Kampf politisch
mitführt es macht eben einen Unterschied
dass eine Frau als Chef Diplomat in den
Ton abgeben erst recht für diese
Regierung in diesem Sinne Frau Leben
Freiheit
vielen Dank
von den bündnisgünden sieht ja eine Art
politischen Hinterhalt der
Unionsfraktion die hat diesen Antrag ja
eingebracht iranische Protestbewegung
entschlossen unterstützen den Testfall
einer frauenorientierten Außenpolitik
zum Erfolg machen wie die Union das
Gemeinder das kann jetzt Johann David
wartepool von der cdu/csu-fraktion
vor dem Parlament
vor dem Parlament sagen werden zum
Beispiel jetzt gerade noch
weitere lösungsanalina behrburg zum 42
Geburtstag gratuliert jetzt wie gesagt
Johann David wartepool von der cdu/csu
Fraktion mit seiner Erklärung was hinter
den Antrag seiner Fraktion steckt den
herzlichen Glück und Segenswünschen für
unsere Außenministerin gerne anschließt
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
die Lage im Iran ist dramatisch die
Brutalität mit der das iranische Regime
gegen die breite Protestbewegung vorgeht
sucht seinesgleichen am 16 September
also vor fast drei Monaten ist die junge
Kurden Maser Gina Amini durch brutales
Vorgehen der Sittenpolizei zu Tode
gekommen dies hat zu den größten
landesweiten Protesten gegen das
islamische Regime im Iran seit der
sogenannten islamischen Revolution im
Jahre 1979 geführt Proteste die im
ersten Moment
von vielen mutigen Frauen getragen
wurden die gegen das repressive Regime
aufbegehrten ein Regime das seit
Jahrzehnten systematisch Frauen
unterdrückt und drangsaliert diesen
Protesten haben sich sukzessive immer
weitere Teile der Bevölkerung
angeschlossen
studentenhändler die Mittelschicht ihre
Forderung ist klar ein grundlegender
Wechsel im herrschafts- und
Gesellschaftssystem im Iran anders als
ihre Eltern Generationen haben über 60
Prozent der iranischen Bevölkerung die
im Übrigen in etwa gleich stark ist wie
die deutsche die unter 30 sind keine
Beziehungen und keine Bindungen zur
islamischen Reform sie wollen eine
andere Staatsform dies versucht das
islamistische Terror-Regime und
Präsident reisi und die
revolutionsgarten zu unterdrücken die
Bilanz ist verheerend
schon jetzt wurden mehr als 18.000
Menschen verhaftet mehr als 400 Menschen
unschuldige Frauen Kinder wurden getötet
Berichte aus Gefängnissen sprechen von
schlimmsten Menschenrechtsverletzungen
Frauen werden vergewaltigt Kinder werden
gefoltert
die
ard-journalistin Natalie Amiri hat der
cdu/csu-fraktion geschildert dass sie am
Sonntag ein Beitrag senden wird wo eine
Minderjährige aus den Gefängnissen
berichtet und von den Schreien anderer
Mädchen erzählt die nach ihrer Mutter
rufen
wir sind im Mittelalter angekommen
es gibt öffentliche Hinrichtungen
dieses Regime hat offensichtlich nichts
mehr zu verlieren es wendet alle
barbarischen Methoden an und deswegen
sind wir alle aufgerufen ist die freie
Welt aufgerufen diesen Menschen diesen
Frauen diesen Kindern der Bevölkerung
des Iran insgesamt zur Seite zu stehen
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
aus Sicht der cdu/csu-fraktionen
reagiert die Bundesregierung darauf
jedoch wie üblich zu spät und sie macht
zu wenig sie sind entweder nicht bereit
oder nicht in der Lage das historische
Momentum und die notwendige Rolle
Deutschlands zu definieren und eine
darauf aufbauende konsistente
Außenpolitik zu formulieren erst am 26
September ganze 10 Tage nach der
Ermordung aminis hat sich die
bundesaußenministerin per Twitter
öffentlich zur Gewalt gegen
Demonstranten geäußert und meine lieben
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das haben die
Grünen uns ja gerade eben noch einmal
vorgehalten
feministische Außenpolitik verdient nur
dann
die Anwendung dieser Begriffe hier wenn
die Außenpolitik in ihren praktischen
Taten den eigenen Ansprüchen auch
gerecht wird und das ist nicht der Fall
das ist nicht der Fall
dazu kommt der Bundeskanzler
der Bundes der Bundeskanzler hat bis zum
26 September gebraucht bis er überhaupt
etwas dazu gesagt hat
gestern in der
Regierungserklärung vorkommen richtig
haben wir vom Bundeskanzler 20 Minuten
über internationale Politik gehört und
kein Satz zum Iran kein Wort keine Silbe
es ist Unfähigkeit ist es Unwille daher
deswegen muss ich noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass Mindeste was die
Inhaftierten die gefolterten von uns
erwarten können ist doch dass wir ihnen
eine Stimme verleihen und deswegen wäre
es die vornehmste Aufgabe des
Bundeskanzlers der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland gewesen hier an dieser
Stelle etwas dazu zu sagen und eine
klare Position für die unsere
Deutschland zu formulieren das ist nicht
geschehen und deswegen kann ich sie nur
auffordern
einmal anschauen und auch die konkreten
Forderungen sich anschauen was dort drin
steht es muss doch konkret darum gehen
dass Regime in Teheran maximal unter
Druck zu setzen ihren handlungs- und
Bewegungs Bewegungsspielraum
größtmöglich einzuschrecken
einzuschränken wie kann es sein dass wir
dieser Tage zur Kenntnis nehmen dort
Deutschland immer noch der größte
Handelspartner des Iran in der EU ist
glauben ich würde gerne fortfahren in
ihrem Antrag sprechen Sie davon das
müsste mal geprüft werden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren in dieser
Zeit muss mehr gemacht werden als zu
prüfen sie müssen handeln die
Bundesregierung muss endlich etwas
praktisch tun
warum ist es Kanada möglich die
iranischen revolutionsgarten
komplett zu sanktionieren warum gibt es
in der Europäischen Union jetzt ein
erstes kleines sanktionspaketchen und
keine vollständige Sanktionierung der
Garden warum ist es immer noch möglich
dass die Kinder der revolutionsgarten in
Eliteschulen in Europa zur Schule gehen
und sich hier frei bewegen und diese
diese Schicht ein Leben in Saus und
ausführt hier muss mehr gemacht werden
hier muss Deutschland in eine
Führungsrolle gehen
warum
besteht das islamische Zentrum in
Hamburg immer noch als Drehscheibe der
Spionage und der auslandsrepression
dieses Regimes Bürgermeister Scholz sein
Nachfolger Tschentscher haben an der
Stelle nichts unter normal meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren wir erwarten
von der Bundesregierung dass sie diese
Außenstelle
dreams hier schließt es muss endlich
etwas geschehen der Iran so wie er unter
diesem Regime agiert
außenpolitisch und in der Region steht
gegen alles was Deutschland wichtig ist
gegen Menschenrechte er stellt die
Existenz Israels in Frage er
verunsichert die gesamte Region
führt Militärschläge im Irak durch die
stabilisiert den Libanon meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren dieses Regime
steht gegen alles was Deutschland
wichtig ist und deswegen deutsche
Außenpolitik muss eine neue Iran-Politik
sein und muss sich endlich diesen Regime
widersetzen der Iran diese großen Kultur
Nation ist größer und dem müssen wir in
unserer Außenpolitik endlich gerecht
werden danke schön
dieser Antrag der Unionsfraktion ist vor
ca 8 Wochen schon einmal hier im Plenum
behandelt Monaten heute sind noch mal
für die Debatte 70 Minuten angesetzt
danach eine Abstimmung also bis etwa 12
Uhr nächste Rednerin Deria Türk
Nachbauer von der SPD sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin erst einmal herzlichen
Glückwunsch zum Geburtstag liebe Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen liebe Menschen im Iran
wer wird der oder wer wird die nächste
sein das ist die quälende Frage für
Millionen Iranerinnen und Iraner die sie
in den Schlaf begleitet und morgens
schweißgebadet aufstrecken lässt
eine iranische Freundin erzählt mir dass
sie mit dem Handy in der Hand einschläft
und der erste Blick am Morgen Ihrem
Telefon gilt aus Sorge vor weiteren
schlimmen Nachrichten nach der
Hinrichtung der zwei jungen
Demonstranten und Malteser
noch viel viel unerträglicher geworden
Marcel und Madrid haben beide gerade
erst einmal erst 23 Jahre alt mOssen
wurde am Donnerstag in Tätern
hingerichtet und Malteser am Montag in
Madrid sie hätten einen Krieg gegen Gott
und gegen die islamische Ordnung geführt
sagt die Justiz ein Vorwurf der
aktuellen mindestens 38 weiteren
Inhaftierten Demonstranten das Leben
kosten wird wenn sich dieses terrorree
nicht aufhalten lässt wird es heute das
Brüderpaar Verhalten treffen oder den
19-Jährigen Mohammed organi wie viele
junge Frauen wie ein Mieter Abi werden
noch in den Gefängnissen brutals
vergewaltigt werden um dann spurlos zu
verschwinden noch wie viele Mütter wie
viele Väter wären ihre Kinder zu Grabe
tragen müssen und mit dem Leichnam die
ungelebten Hoffnung und Träume ihrer
Kinder beerdigen ich weiß es nicht wir
wissen es nicht was wir allerdings
wissen ist dass dieser staatlich
angeordnete Terror sofort aufhören muss
heute
heute sind so 90 Tage in diesen 90 Tagen
wurden mehr als 18.000 Menschen
inhaftiert tausende vergewaltigt und
gefoltert über 460 getötet darunter über
60 Kinder die Demonstrierenden Menschen
im Iran zeigen uns das kostbarste Gut
ist die Freiheit es will mit Loyalität
und Mut verteidigt werden der Ruf nach
Freiheit lässt sich nicht einsperren die
Hoffnung auf Zukunft lässt sich nicht
vergewaltigen die Träume der Jugend
lassen sich nicht auspeitschen diese
Erkenntnis
diese Erkenntnis schüchtert die Führung
der islamischen Islamischen Republik
Iran ein der Mut dieser Protestierenden
Frauen und der Jugend auf den
straßenversetzt kamen in Angst und
Schrecken kann man nie was ganz genau
dass er alles verlieren wird wenn diese
mutigen Menschen in Iran Straßen Schulen
und Universitäten nicht gestoppt werden
die Protestbewegung ist zu einer
Revolutionsbewegung geworden es gibt
kein zurück mehr das Ausmaß und die
Dauer des zivilen Aufstands gegen die
Molas und ihr Regime haben eine seit
Jahrzehnten nicht gesehene Wucht
erreicht das weiß die islamistische
Führung und daher ist jedes Mittel recht
diese willkürlich ausgesprochenen
Todesurteile sollen Stärke demonstrieren
sollen die Menschen einschüchtern diese
Exekution sind ein Signal der Schwäche
und der Angst an die Herren
Entscheidungsträger im Iran sie haben
Angst vor ihren eigenen Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern sie haben Angst vor Lehrer Lust
sie sind zwar besser ausgerüstet sie
haben das Geld sie haben die Strukturen
sie haben einen Überwachungsapparat sie
haben Partner die zu Ihnen passen aber
sie haben keine Zukunft die Zukunft
gehört der Freiheit
wir Demokratin
stehen dabei ganz fest an der Seite der
Unterdrückten Menschen das haben wir mit
dem von der Koalition eingebrachten und
beschlossenen Antrag vor wenigen Wochen
ziemlich deutlich zum Ausdruck gebracht
ohne die Frauen im Iran zum Testfall
erklären zu müssen ich wiederhole mich
weil ich das schon in der ersten Debatte
zu diesem Antrag gesagt habe die Frauen
im Iran sind weder ein testball noch als
spielwahl irgendwelche Parteipolitik
liebe Kollegen von der Union das wissen
sie auch viele was sie bereits gefordert
ist bereits Beschlusslage und vieles
anderes in Arbeit auch ich möchte die
revolutionsgarten geschlossen auf dieser
Terrorliste sehen ich ich möchte auch
die Abgeordneten des iranischen
Parlaments die für diese unmenschlichen
Hinrichtung plädieren auf genau dieser
Terrorliste sehen ich möchte auch die
Staatsanwälte und Richter die für diese
Exekution verantwortlich sind auf genau
dieser terroristisch stehen es ist
also einfach wie wir uns das wünschen
dass EU-Recht ist doch ziemlich klar
grundlage ist die kaum zu Nummer sage
ich ihnen nicht aber es ist dokumentiert
erste Voraussetzung ist dass eine
nationale strafverfolgungs- oder
Ermittlungsbehörde in einen
EU-Mitgliedstaat ein Verfahren
eingeleitet hat oder eine Verurteilung
erfolgt ist das ist bislang nicht der
Fall aber das wissen sie doch auch wir
tun alles was momentan rechtlich möglich
ist und da hat sich zum Glück schon
einiges getan auf Antrag Deutschlands
hat sich der Menschenrechtsrat der
Vereinten Nation Ende November mit der
Lage im Iran befasst
und für diese unabhängigen Untersuchung
der anhaltenden Gewalt gegen
demonstrierende gestimmt der Iran ist
gestern erst auf Betreiben der USA aus
einem UN-Gremium für Frauenrechte
ausgeschlossen worden das sind so
wichtige Zeichen bislang sind über 50
Einzelpersonen mit Revolution oder mit
Bezug auf revolutionsgarten gelistet
entweder im Rahmen des spezifischen Iran
sanktionsregimes oder im Rahmen des
menschenrechtssanktionsrechts die Liste
wäre lang es sind Banken sanktioniert es
sind Geldgeber sanktioniert es ist das
halbe abwehrkommen Kommando sanktioniert
die Listung weiterer Person das ist
alles in Arbeit die Menschen im Iran
brauchen die Geschlossenheit aller
Demokratien im Bundestag das bleibt
dieser Menschen eignet sich überhaupt
nicht dazu
parteipolische profilaktion hier
profilierungsaktionen hier zu starten
die Menschen im Iran die Menschen im
Iran und auch die iranische Community
bei uns hier in Deutschland brauchen
unser aller Stimme unseren Schutz und
unsere Unterstützung und vor allem eine
ehrliche und sachliche Erklärung des
EU-Rechts mit Parteipolitik ist in
dieser Situation wirklich niemanden
geholfen mit einigen iranischen Freunden
habe ich ausgemacht dass wir spätestens
an der Brust am Brandenburger Tor das
Ende dieses Müller Regimes tanzend
feiern ich hoffe Sie sind dann auch
dabei vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
soweit der regiertürk Nachbau von der
SPD zur Iran Debatte im Bundestag
nächster Redner jetzt von der
afd-fraktion Eugen Schmidt er ist
stellvertretendes Mitglied des
Auswärtigen Ausschusses
Feind mir nicht der Fall zu sein
schriftführerinnen und Schriftführer mit
der Auszählung zu Beginn das Ergebnis
wird später bekannt gegeben
meinte damit die laufende namentliche
Abstimmung zur
gaspreisbremse die ist jetzt beendet das
Ergebnis wird gleich bekannt gegeben und
wie gesagt jetzt Eugen Schmidt von der
AFD Fraktion
Liebe Landsleute
ein sehr großer Teil der iranischen
Bevölkerung ist unzufrieden mit der
politischen und gesellschaftlichen Orden
im Land die mutigen Demonstrationen
viele Iraner gegen Kopftuchzwang und für
Freiheit sind unbedingt anerkennenswert
die FD sagt die vormundung und
Islamismus nein Freiheit ja auch hier
und vor allem in Deutschland denn die
vor wir uns mit anderen Ländern befassen
sollten wir die Probleme im eigenen Land
angehen es gibt ein massives
islamismusproblem in Deutschland das ist
offensichtlich aber die Bundesregierung
versteht hier vor die Augen das ist das
eine das andere ist über die innere
Ordnung muss in jeweiligen Land selbst
entschieden werden Deutschland sollte
hierfür auch Dialog setzen und seine
Unterstützung anbieten die
Bundesregierung muss mit der iranischen
Führung ins Gespräch kommen und
Spannungen abzubauen Deutschland sollte
Krisen entschärfen und nicht anfeuern
Gewalt darf kein Mittel sein egal von
welcher Seite
hunderte Tote Demonstranten aber auch
rund 60 getötete Sicherheitskräfte das
darf sich keinesfalls wiederholen wir
können uns keinen weiteren Bürgerkrieg
im nahosten erlauben wir wollen
Gespräche sowohl mit Führung als auch
Oppositionskräften falls vom iranischen
Volk gewollt ist könnte Deutschland als
Vermieter eine wichtige Rolle übernehmen
doch
Außenministerin hat das traditionell
vertrauensvolle deutsche rheinische
Verhältnis schwer beschädigt sie setzt
sich stattdessen dafür ein dass deutsche
Waffen an Saudi Arabien geliefert werden
hierdurch wird der blutige
weltweit der im Jemen ist weiter
befeuert
Heuchelei und Selbstgefälligkeit
Markenzeichen grüne Außenpolitik und die
Union Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
Union lehnen in ihrem Antrag
diplomatische Mittel der Handlungen
Gespräche ausdrücklich ab
stattdessen wollen sie Druck ausüben sie
schreiben weiter in ihrem Antrag die
konkrete Verbesserung der Lage der
Frauen im Iran muss Gradmesser für den
Erfolg der deutschen und europäischen
Frauen produzierten Außenpolitik sein
das bedeutet der Erfolg deutsche
Außenpolitik mit sich daran inwiefern
sie die innere Situation eines anderen
Landwirte die Außenpolitik der Werbung
sind noch nicht genug
das ist oberflächlich arrogant
lächerlich und besorgniserregend wollen
sie die Grünen überholen die Politik der
Union und der Regierungsfraktionen sieht
auf Regimewechsel ab dabei hat diese
Politik in den vergangenen 20 Jahren
unzählige Menschenleben gekostet ganze
Länder wurden verwüstet Afghanistan Irak
Libyen Syrien
migrationsstürme wurden ausgelost und
teren befeuert die Ehre und Gewalt
gelangten auch in unser Land doch diese
Bundesregierung und auch die Union will
Krisen nicht entschärfen im Gegenteil
sie haben eine Neigung zu gewaltsamen
Losungen
sie haben nichts auf den letzten 20
Jahren misslungene westliche
intuitionspolitik gelernt hierzu kann
AFD nur nein sagen wir sind ja
Alternative für Freiheit gegen Gängelung
für Diplomatie und gegen Gewalt und vor
allem und stets an erster Stelle für
Deutschland
AFD die friedensparteien
ja Eugen Schmidt von der AFD mit
zumindestens teilweise Verständnis für
das Regime in Teheran erstaunlich für
eine Fraktion die sonst immer auf die
Gefahren die durch Islam und Islamismus
in Deutschland
stehen können Hinweis nächster Redner
ist Rainer sind von der FDP viele
Menschen hier in Berlin versammelt um
ein Zeichen der Solidarität mit den
Frauen und Männern im Iran zu setzen
Frau Leben Freiheit stand leuchtend in
mehreren Sprachen am Brandenburger Tor
wir stehen unter dem Eindruck der
grausamen öffentlichen Hinrichtungen der
hohen Gewalt auf den Straßen der
Verschleppungen mit denen das mularegime
verzweifelt versucht die Bevölkerung von
ihrem Freiheitskampf abzuhalten unser
Mitgefühl gilt in Angehörigen und
Freunden der Getöteten sie trauen um
ihre Heldinnen und Helden für unsere
Maßnahmen die Freiheitsbewegung zu
unterstützen und das Regime zu schwächen
heißt das jetzt erst recht
wir begrüßen als Freie Demokraten ganz
ausdrücklich die neuen Sanktionen die da
Außenministerrat Anfang der Woche in
Brüssel beschlossen hat sie enthalten
Einreiseverbote in die EU und Konto
Sperrungen mit den Sanktionen treffen
wir auch Kommandeure die die Befehle zu
den grausamen Taten gegeben haben zum
Beispiel beispielsweise einen Kopf der
iranischen Ordnungskräfte in der Provinz
sistan und belucistan er ist
verantwortlich für mehrere Massaker bei
denen protestieren der erschossen wurden
unter anderem in zachern am 30 September
und in Kasch am 4 November diese Listen
werden fortgeschrieben und laufend die
Bundesregierung wird alle Möglichkeiten
ausschöpfen um die Täter zu
Verantwortung zu ziehen und die
Profiteure des Regimes mit den
Sanktionen zu treffen
unseren Kindern bringen wir bei wer
anderen Menschen absichtlich schadet
wird dafür bestraft und wir bringen auch
bei Verantwortung für Handeln zu
übernehmen
meine Damen und Herren wir wollen auf
internationaler Ebene werden wie
Verantwortung und Freiheit der
persönlichen Lebensgestaltung Ausdruck
verleihen und diejenigen unterstützen
die diese Rechte für sich einfordern und
es gibt keinerlei Legitimation jemanden
diese Rechte zu verweigern
ich freue mich dass maßgeblich die
deutsche Bundesregierung dafür
verantwortlich ist dass der
Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten Nationen
auf seiner Sondersitzung vor drei Wochen
beschlossen hat eine unabhängige
Untersuchungskommission einzurichten
diese Kommission wird
Menschenrechtsverletzungen im Iran
identifizieren Beweismittel sammeln und
alle staatlichen und überstaatlichen
Instanzen in die Aufarbeitung einbinden
ja es ist politisch ein erster Erfolg
wenn Rechtssprüche verurteilt und damit
Druck auf die Verantwortlichen ausgeübt
wird aber machen wir uns bitte nichts
vor
Mehrheitsentscheidungen zugunsten von
Freiheit Demokratie und Menschenrechten
sind internationalen Gremien alles
andere als ein Selbstläufer
dem un- Menschenrechtsrat gehören 47
Mitgliedsstaaten an die Abstimmung zur
Einrichtung der Untersuchungskommission
viel mit 25 Jahre Stimmen
sechseinstellungen bei 16 Enthaltungen
aus das bedeutet 22 Mitglieder haben
sich also entschieden eine unabhängig
Untersuchung nicht zu befürworten fast
alles Länder in denen mehr oder weniger
abhängig die mehr oder weniger abhängig
von den großen Autokratien dieser Welt
sind um weltweit Freiheit und
Menschenrechte für Menschenrechte
eintreten zu können müssen wir den
systemwettbewerb ernst nehmen indem wir
uns mit China und Russland längst
befinden
der Uran wurde gestern aus der Menschen
frauenrechtskommission der Vereinten
Nation ausgeschlossen die sich für genau
diese Rechte einsetzt die die Mullahs
und ihre Handlanger so sehr fürchten das
ist das richtige Signal und ein
wichtiger weiterer Baustein der
Isolation der Staatsführung die
internationale Staatengemeinschaft zeigt
damit dass sie Gewalt und Unterdrückung
als regierungsmethode nicht billigt
und mit harten Konsequenzen versieht
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen geben wir
auch weiterhin der iranischen
Freiheitsbewegung all die Aufmerksamkeit
und Unterstützung die sie verdient und
benötigt danke schön
die von Rainer semeth erwähnte der von
Rainer semeth wenn der Ausschluss des
Iraners der UN-Kommission für die Rechte
der Frauen der wurde übrigens mit den
Gegenstimmen von Russland und China
angenommen nächste Rednerin ist schon in
Wisla die Parteivorsitzende der Linken
am 16 September wurde
die
Teil Gewahrsam getötet die Sittenpolizei
hatte sie wegen eines angeblichen
Verstoßes gegen die islamischen
Kleidungsvorschriften festgenommen sie
starb 5 Tage vor ihrem 23 Geburtstag ihr
Tod wurde zum Kanal und zum
Ausgangspunkt einer landesweiten
Protestbewegung im Iran seit drei
Monaten halten die Massenproteste und
Streiks gegen die Unterdrückung durch
das molaregime an einer Revolution bei
der Frauen Vorreiterin sind ihr ruft
nach einem lebenden Würde und Freiheit
hat verschiedene Teile der iranischen
Gesellschaft vereint mit einem
dreitägigen Generalstreik in der
vergangene Woche erreicht die
Protestbewegung eine neue Dimension
Lkw-Fahrer Beschäftigte in Fabriken in
der Ölindustrie streikten was im Iran
gerade passiert ist historisch unsere
Solidarität gilt den Protestierenden wir
unterstützen ihren Kampf für einen
demokratischen und sozialen Iran und wir
haben Hochachtung vor der Mut und ihrer
Entschlossenheit
denn das Regime
Brutalität fast 500 demonstrierende
sollen getötet worden sein und fast
18.000 festgenommen darunter Kinder und
Jugendliche die Gefangenen berichten von
Folter und Vergewaltigung und besonders
gefährlich ist die Situation für die
Menschen in Kurdistan und belucistan die
seit Jahrzehnten drangsaliert und
marginalisiert werden die Regierung
versucht die Menschen mit Todesurteilen
und Hinrichtungen einzuschüchtern und
zum Aufgeben zu bewegen
moscenter
wurden in einigen scheinprozessen zum
Tode verurteilt und hingerichtet beide
waren 23 Jahre alt ihr Verbrechen
Teilnahme an Protesten vielen anderen
verhafteten droht ebenfalls die
Todesstrafe es ist nicht das erste Mal
dass das Regime solche Methoden der
Abschreckung einsetzt um Widerstand zu
unterdrücken allein im Sommer 1988
wurden tausende politische Gefangene in
drei minütigen Gerichtsverhandlungen zum
Tode verurteilt und in Gräbern wir
Caravan bei Teheran verscharrt und der
heutige Präsident raizi war schon damals
an den Morden beteiligt aber die
Menschen lassen sich nicht einschüchtern
sie protestieren weiter trotz alledem
und einige Abgeordnete die aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag haben ja politische
Patenschaften für zum Tode verurteilte
Menschen übernommen um Solidarität zu
zeigen mit den Verurteilten wir haben ja
gerade gehört es gibt eine Fraktion die
auf Seiten der Mullah steht das ist die
AFD das haben sie ja deutlich gemacht
ist ja auch interessant zu hören
meine Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler
darf nicht weiter schweigen die
Bundesregierung muss alle diplomatischen
Mittel einsetzen um den Druck auf das
Regime zu erhöhen und weitere
Hinrichtungen zu verhindern die
humanitäre Visa und passvergabe muss
erleichtert werden und natürlich muss es
einen dauerhaften Abschiebestopp in den
Iran geben nicht nur im Iran Leben
iranische Oppositionellen Angst auch in
Deutschland werden Exil Iranerinnen vom
Regime bespitzelt eingeschüchtert und
drangsaliert erinnern wir an das
erinnern wir uns an das mykonosat 1992
bei dem iranisch kurdische
Oppositionelle in Berlin durch das
iranische Regime grausam ermordet wurden
das Wirken dass iranischen Geheimdienst
in Deutschland das muss endlich
entschieden bekämpft werden meine Damen
und Herren und die Bundesregierung muss
Mittel bereitstellen um
Menschenrechtsverletzungen zu
dokumentieren damit Täter auch zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden können
meine Damen und Herren die protestieren
im Iran schreiben Geschichte
Aktivistin sagt nein die Menschen wollen
keine Reform die eindeutig und zentrale
Forderung ist der Sturz der Islamischen
Republik es hat sich im
Kern der grundlegend für etwas verändert
es ist ein Punkt erreicht an dem es
trotz der Repression kein Zurück mehr
gibt und ich will den Protestierenden
sagen die Welt schaut auf euch die Welt
schaut auf eure Revolution nach Pablo
Neruda sie können alle Blumen
abschneiden aber sie können den Frühling
nicht verhindern nie wieder da waren
nächster Redner ist Jürgen Trittin für
Bündnis 90 die Grünen ich hatte einen
Moment gezögert in der Annahme dass das
Abstimmungsergebnis über die
gaspreisbremse kommt das kommt noch
nicht jetzt Jürgen vor den Bündnisgrünen
der Iran ist im Nahen Osten etwas
Besonderes übrigens im Guten und das
liegt an den Menschen
die Mehrheit der Iranerinnen und Iraner
möchte eine strikte Trennung von Staat
und Religion
sie wollen nicht mehr in einem
sogenannten Gottesstaat leben
und diese klare Haltung beruht auf den
Erfahrungen
mit einer islamischen Republik die sich
selbst als Gottesstaat definiert
doch was ist das für ein Gottesstaat
der seine Herrschaft auf den Strang
stützt welchen Gott ist das gefährlich
was ist das für ein Staat
der seit Jahren Minderjährige ermordet
der Rapper mit dem galgendroht
heute stehen 23 Menschen vor der
Vollstreckung der Todesstrafe
unzählige Verhaftung
tote Menschen die für Frauen Frieden
Freiheit auf die Straße gegangen sind
sie werden nicht nur mit dem Tode
bedroht sondern die öffentlichen
Hinrichtungen sollen sie einschüchtern
diesen Menschen gilt unsere
uneingeschränkte Solidarität
Frauen Frieden Freiheit
das hat vor einigen Wochen
einen Fraktionsvorsitzenden hier
schenkelklopfen des Gelächter ausgelöst
nun legt die
cdu/csu eine
Antrag für eine frauenorientierte
Außenpolitik vor und da sieht man eine
Entwicklung
dann würde ich
lieber Kollege wadepool
auch in aller Freundlichkeit anmerken
dass sie genau wissen dass sie an dieser
Frage mit rhetorischen Fragen nicht
weiterkommen sie wissen sie wissen dass
es Voraussetzungen gibt
die für einen solche Listung
beispielsweise notwendig sind oder auch
für die Schließung eines iranischen
Zentrums was dieser Bundestag schon
lange fordert
aber sie hätten auch hinzufügen können
dass Deutschland das einzige Land ist in
dem nach dem Schüssen auf die Essener
Synagoge nun mit den Ermittlungen des
Generalbundesanwalts ein solcher
Verfahren eingeleitet wird was die
voraussetzungslehre für die Listung der
revolutionsgarten als Terrororganisation
und das ist das woran diese
Außenministerin sehr hart arbeitet und
liebe Frau Wissler
ich teile viel von dem was Sie gesagt
haben aber wer es dann nicht einfacher
gewesen am 28.9 im Menschenrechtsrat mit
den anderen Fraktionen der Resolution
zum Iran zuzustimmen anstatt sich zu
enthalten
ich glaube bevor man mit
sondergeschichte andere der Untätigkeit
bezichtigt sollte man mal zur Kenntnis
nehmen das was im unmen
Menschenrechtsrat durchgesetzt worden
ist und Sie haben ja recht der Kollege
dass ich 16 enthalten haben aber wir
müssen mal feststellen dass sich Länder
wie Usbekistan und Kasachstan enthalten
haben die verkehrlich total von Iran
auch abhängig sind das ist schon ein
Erfolg dass sie nicht mit Nein gestimmt
haben und dieser Erfolg geht zurück
unter anderem auf die Reise der
bundesaußenministerin in diese Länder wo
Sie aktiv an dieser Stelle genau für
diese Politik geworden hat und wenn
jemand wissen will was feministische
Außenpolitik ist dann ist das ein
Beispiel für feministische Außenpolitik
meine Damen und Herren
diese Ministerin die das dritte
Sanktionspaket vorangetrieben hat
übrigens nicht nur die Terroraktion
gegen die eigene Bevölkerung
sanktioniert sondern auch die
Unterstützung des Irans für den
drohnenkrieg Russlands in der Ukraine
das solche
Hütte
sinnese einer feministischen
Außenpolitik und es ist die Antwort auf
ein Regime das sich auf Gott beruft aber
eine satanische Politik betreibt
soweit irgendwie von den Bündnis Grünen
jetzt kommt jürgen hat als nächster
Redner von Unionsfraktion er ist der
außenpolitische Sprecher seiner Fraktion
hier im Bundestag Jürgen hart
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir als
cdu/csu-fraktionen haben den iran-antrag
heute hier auch in der Kernzeit auf die
Tagesordnung gesetzt aus zwei Gründen
zum einen
weil wir im Iran in diesen Tagen und
Wochen eine massive Verschärfung der
Brutalität des Regimes gegen die
zwiebelwirkung sehen in Schauprozessen
werden junge Menschen abgeurteilt und
hingerichtet das ist etwas was uns
zutiefst beunruhigt und schockiert und
zum anderen beunruhigt und schockiert
uns die nach wie vor aus unserer Sicht
zu zögerliche Haltung der
Bundesregierung in der Europäischen
Union wenn es um die Antwort auf diese
Taten geht und deswegen ist es gut dass
wir heute hierüber diskutieren
jetzt sind in der Europäischen Union
wieder weitere zwei Dutzend alte graue
Männer die im Zweifel ihren Fuß sowieso
nicht für die Tür setzen hinterheran auf
die Sanktionsliste gesetzt worden
wir fordern als
cdu/csu-fraktion ein deutlich härteres
Sanktionsregime gegen den Iran
wir fordern dass die
revolutionären gaten als
Terrororganisation gelistet werden was
verschiedene Wirkungen hätte nämlich zum
ersten die Wirkung hätte dass junge
Menschen im Iran junge Männer im Iran
Wissen in dem Fall dass sie sich
anwerben lassen für diesen Teil des
staatsoperats sie einer
Terrororganisation angehören und dann
Blick auf ihre Zukunft was Reisefreiheit
was studiermöglichkeiten was Geschäfte
angeht extrem eingeschränkt sind um zum
zweiten weil wir natürlich auch
diejenigen damit treffen die Geschäfte
machen mit diesen revolutionsgarten und
man muss ja wissen dass sie Meran ein
großer Teil der wirtschaftswirtschaft
ist und dass ein wesentlicher Teil der
Staatswirtschaft eben von diesem Garten
kontrolliert wird jetzt hat uns die
Bundesregierung und er Trittin hat das
hier übernommen gerade gesagt es gäbe
nationale und europäische rechts
Sachverhalte die uns daran hindern das
zu tun die Frage die ich dabei Stelle
ist wenn es nationale Gesetze gibt die
uns daran hindern diese führende
Terrororganisation dieser Welt die ja
nicht nur das Volk im Iran unterdrückt
sondern die auch Kampf gegen Israel
führt die in Jemen die Terrorgruppen
unterstützt die in die Spoiler
unterstützt die im Syrien massiv wirkt
wenn es nicht gelingt aufgrund deutscher
Gesetze so etwas auch als
Terrororganisation einzuschätzen dann
möchte ich als Abgeordneter wissen
welche Gesetze müssen wir ändern um das
entsprechend tun zu können
das zweite es gibt eine eu-terrorliste
also erstens sind wir nicht einig mit
der Regierung das tatsächlich das
europäische Recht es untersagt diesen
Schritt jetzt zu gehen und zum zweiten
ständig auch da die Frage wenn das
europäische Recht nicht in der Lage ist
so etwas zu tun diese Listung als
Terrororganisation in diesem Fall dann
müssen wir überprüfen ob wir das
europäische Recht weiterentwickeln
müssen und da warte ich dann einen
Initiative der deutschen Regierung ein
zweiter
ein zweiter Punkt der mir sehr wichtig
ist und da kann ich nur an die Regierung
appellieren dass sehr ernst zu nehmen
wir erleben dass die Iran als mutmaß
sich gegenwärtig der einzige
Unterstützer Russlands was konkrete
Rüstungsgüter angeht
massives Schäden anrichtet in der
Ukraine ukrainische Kindergärten werden
getroffen von Drohnen die die Russen
einsetzen weil sie sie vom Iran bekommen
haben
die Frage ist wie ist der Rhein in der
Lage sollte Drohnen zu bauen und zu
exportieren da gibt es Presseberichte
das möglicherweise Mikroelektronik aus
Gütern die nicht einmal als duellius zu
betrachten sind zum Beispiel
Waschmaschinen möglicherweise Eingang in
diese iranischen Drohnen finden und das
damit letztlich auf diesem Umweg der ran
in der Lage versetzt wird diese Drohnen
zur Verfügung zu stellen ich kann die
Bundesregierung nur dringend auffordern
diesen Presseberichten aus der Financial
Times zum Beispiel intensiv nachzugehen
denn es wäre ein großer Schaden für
Deutschland für das deutsche ansehen und
natürlich für das ukrainische Volk sind
tatsächlich Bauteile aus Deutschland am
Ende sich in diesem Drohnen finden
würden und wir werden das im Ausschuss
entsprechend thematisieren
der dritte Punkt der mir wichtig ist zu
sagen die Bundesregierung
übt aus meiner Sicht zu große
Zurückhaltung gegenüber den regimeteran
vielleicht auch weil sie hofft doch noch
beim atomabkommen GC Poe zu einem
Ergebnis zu kommen um das hier klar zu
sagen ein solches Abkommen wollen wir
auch die Frage ob das ein realistischer
Weg eine Perspektive für die nächsten
Monate ist da mache ich ein großes
Fragezeichen ich sehe zum Beispiel nicht
Thema heute im amerikanischen Kongress
die die Wiederaufnahme eines solchen
Abkommens beschwortet was sich bei
dieser Regierung vermisse ist nicht dass
man das Engagement fortsetzt zu
versuchen es hinzukriegen sondern dass
wir keinen Plan B haben was wir
eigentlich machen mit der atomaren
Bewaffnung des Iran wenn es zu diesem
Abkommen nicht kommt auch über diese
Frage müssen wir hier in diesem
Deutschen Bundestag müssen wir im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss intensiv
diskutieren und ich hoffe dass wir die
Gemeinsamkeit der Demokraten dieser
Frage beantragen herzlichen Dank
soweit Jürgen h von der Unionsfraktion
nächster Redner skw-mannsuri von der SPD
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin Kolleginnen und
Kollegen Liebe zuschauende ich möchte
Ihnen von faserne und ihrem Ehemann
Hamid erzählen zwei politische Gefangene
im Iran für die ich die Patenschaft
übernommen habe ein Ehepaar bekannt für
seinen Einsatz und seine Unterstützung
in Krisengebieten bei der medizinischen
Versorgung und Unterstützung von Kindern
am 3 November sind sie nach der
Trauerfeier für eine junge durch das
Regime ermordete Frau aus Sicht des
mularegims zur falschen Zeit am falschen
Ort in der Nacht wird das Ehepaar von
Sicherheitskräften zu Hause überfallen
vor den Augen ihrer Kinder schwer
misshandelt und verschleppt
im Gefängnis werden sie gefoltert und
erpresst falsche Geständnisse abzulegen
Hamid erleidet innere Blutungen und
rippenfrakturen
das scheingerichtsverfahren gegen ihn
und seine Frau wird ohne rechtlichen
Beistand Ihrer Wahl durchgeführt faserne
wird eine Aussage verweigert Hamid wird
ohne Beweise und unter Missachtung
rechtsstaatlicher Mindeststandards zu
Tode verurteilt seine Frau faserne zu 25
Jahren Haft ohne Besuchsrecht
das Ziel ist liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den Anschein von
Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu wahren und die
Menschen zum Schweigen zu bringen aber
sie können nicht die ganze Welt zum
Schweigen bringen das hier ist ein Haus
der freien Rede liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
der freiheitlich demokratischen Bewegung
werfen die Mullahs Krieg gegen Gott vor
doch die Menschen im Iran rebellieren
nicht gegen Gott
sie rebellieren gegen dieses Regime
dieses Regime verwechselt sich selbst
mit Gott
und sie brechen die elementarsten Regeln
menschliche Zivilisation Fritz Bauer
bezeichnete Zivilisation als eine sehr
dünne Decke die schnell abblättert
mit Schauprozessen Mord an Kindern
Massenhinrichtungen beweist das Regime
wie recht er hatte deswegen ist es auch
international isoliert und das ist auch
gut so
die Opfer der Revolution haben Gesichter
sie haben Geschichten und Botschaften
und diese lassen sich in einer freien
Welt nicht auslöschen viele in diesem
Parlament haben
Patenschaften für die über 18.000
politischen Gefangenen im Land
übernommen lassen Sie die Welt hören wer
die Menschen sind die von den mullas in
Folterkammern gesteckt werden es ist
wichtig dass wir laut sind für sie denn
die Menschen im Iran können uns hören
und sie sollen wissen es ist ihre
Revolution aber im Kampf für Freiheit
und Selbstbestimmung sind Sie nicht
allein wir stehen an ihrer Seite
mehrere EU sanktionspakete sind bereits
verabschiedet diese Woche ist ein
weiteres hinzugekommen unser Parlament
hat dem Regime vor Wochen jegliche
Legitimation abgesprochen im un-
Menschenrechtsrat ist auch dank der
Außenministerin eine Mehrheit gegen das
iranische Regime zustande gekommen und
will die Gewalt im Land unabhängig
untersuchen auch die aus der
UN-Kommission für Frauenrechte wurde das
Land nun ausgeschlossen das zeigt der
internationale Druck hilft und wichtig
ist dass wir mit dem Druck nicht
nachlassen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen mit einer Regierung die
Mordanschläge in Deutschland auch schon
hat durchführen lassen und offenbar
weitere plante werden wir nicht auf
Augenhöhe zusammenarbeiten die Spirale
der Gewalt braucht eine
unmissverständliche Antwort das ist
maximaler Druck gegen dieses Regime
und auch deswegen ist es wichtig
dass eine Terrororganisation wie die
Revolutionswächter auf eine Terrorliste
kommen und auch deswegen ist wichtig
dass sämtliche Abgeordnete die ihre Hand
für die Massenhinrichtungen gehoben
werden ebenfalls persönlich sanktioniert
werden liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und zugleich braucht es Unterstützung
für die Zivilbevölkerung die seit Jahren
unter den internationalen Sanktionen am
stärksten leidet keiner von uns weiß wie
lange
der Kampf bis zur Befreiung des Irans
dauern wird und weil das so ist dürfen
die Menschen im Land nicht auf sich
selbst gestellt sein freie Kommunikation
Austausch mit Kulturschaffenden Presse
Wissenschaft Versorgung mit Hilfsgütern
das ist wofür wir einen konkreten
Beitrag leisten können und auch leisten
müssen
bei All
dem wird sein
mit einer Stimme in den zentralen
Punkten spricht
im Iran fragt aktuell keiner
ob du Perser Kurde
Afghane Araber balucce oder
aserbaidschana bist da wird nur gefragt
bist du für einen freien Iran das ist
eine Frage die auch unser Parlament ein
sollte liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Tage der Mullahs sind gezählt für
ihre Taten werden sie sich verantworten
aber das kann ein langer Weg werden
Menschen denen der Tod droht gehen auf
die Straße weil sie an den Sieg von
Freiheit Gerechtigkeit und
Selbstbestimmung glauben und wenn Sie
das tun dann sollten wir das auch setzen
wir auf den Erfolg der Revolution ich
danke Ihnen
soweit kW mansoure von der SPD mit
seinem Appell nächster Redner ist Jürgen
braun von der AFD
Sprecher für Menschenrechte und
humanitäre Hilfe seiner Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren liebe Kollegen als das
islamistische Regime im Iran in den
letzten fünf Jahren
Demonstrationen brutal unterdrückt und
Internetsperren verhängt hat als es den
jungen Sportler na wird Askari verhaftet
und schließlich hingerichtet hat
da kam kein solcher Antrag von CDU und
CSU im Gegenteil als die Union regierte
half sie dem islamistischen Iran sie
stimmte lauthals in das grünen linke
Geschrei gegen Donald Trump und seinen
Ausstieg aus dem atomabkommen ein
dieses sogenannte Abkommen ist dabei nur
eine politische Absichtserklärung gegen
die der Iran zu dem mehrfach verstoßen
hat es ist eine klassische Gutmenschen
aus Geburt der naiven ahnungslosen
Obama-Regierung
die iranische Atombombe hätte diese
Absichtserklärung niemals verhindern
können beim besten Fall verzögern und
auch das nur im allerbesten Fall der
CDU-Außenpolitiker Norbert Röttgen
nannte das fragliche Abkommen dennoch
ein außenpolitisches Glanzstück heute
spricht er nicht mehr davon den Ausstieg
der USA unter Trump selbst Isolierung
und noch vor zwei Jahren während der
Sportler David afkari in Haft gefoltert
wurde bekräftigt die Röntgen es brauche
den Anlauf für ein neues Abkommen neue
Gespräche mit den Urlaubs nachdem das
iranische scheinparlament vor fünf
Wochen beschlossen hat dass allein die
Teilnahme an den Protesten als Krieg
gegen aller eingestuft wird ist der Weg
frei für massenhafte Exekution und die
ersten Todesurteile sind bereits
vollstreckt vor einer Woche haben die
Mullahs einen 23-jährigen gehängt am
Montag folgte der nicht sicher junge
Mann nur Tage zuvor waren Todesurteile
gegen 28
Demonstranten ergangen doch die mutigen
Proteste gegen das islamistische
Gewaltregime gehen trotz aller Drogen
weiter seit drei Monaten
ebenfalls seit drei Monaten klagt
Außenministerin baerbock hier im Hohen
Hause und vor jeder sich bietenden
Kamera mal klagt sie wie schlecht es den
Menschen im Iran gehe mal klagt sie wie
schlecht es ihr selbst ihr angesichts
ihrer schweren Arbeit aber aus den
Gesprächen zum atomabkommen ist sie noch
immer nicht ausgestiegen und die
islamische Revolutionsgarde hat sie noch
immer nicht als Terrororganisation
eingestuft
die AFD ist die einzige Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag die sich konsequent
gegen den politischen Islam stellt und
die sich schon seit Jahren seit vielen
Jahren für die Schließung des
islamischen Zentrums Hamburg einsetzt
sie haben das versäumt sie alle hier mit
uns gibt es keine Halbheiten wie bei der
Ampel und mit uns gibt es auch keine
plötzlichen unglaubwürdigen kehrtwänden
wie bei der Union vielen Dank
Jürgen braun von der AFD mit einem ganz
anderen Zungenschlag als sein
Fraktionskollege Eugen Schmidt vorhin zu
dieser Debatte zum Iran er hat ja
immerhin das Regime in Teheran als
Regime bezeichnet und er hat auch von
einem Terror erschien gesprochen nächste
Rednerin Renata alt von der fdpd
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
iranische Innenminister Amad war die
Demos tertinien und Demonstranten in
Irland kürzlich als Krawallmacher
bezeichnet er will die Ursachen der
Proteste untersuchen lassen ohne die
Protestierenden jedoch zu beteiligen das
zeigt dass die Mutter den Kontakt zu der
eigenen Bevölkerung völlig verloren
haben das ist Reform unwillig es ist der
Reform unfähig es ist gewalttätig und
menschenverachtend
deswegen wollen die Iranerinnen und
Iraner das molare Schimmel Regime
beseitigen die iranischen Frauen und
Männer demonstrieren seit drei Monaten
für die Freiheit für die Demokratie und
für Menschenrechte dabei müssen wir sie
soweit wie möglich unterstützen
hunderte von Demonstranten wurden
bereits getötet darunter viele
Jugendliche und Kinder mehr als 18.000
Demonstranten wurden verhaftet diese
Woche wurden die ersten Gefangenen
gehängt ohne ein faires
Gerichtsverfahren viele Abgeordnete hier
im Hause übernehmen derzeit politische
Patenschaften für inhaftierte in Iran
nicht nur hier aber auch in vielen
Landtagen in Deutschland dafür bin ich
ihnen sehr dankbar liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
wir fordern die Freilassung alle
politischen Gefangenen im Iran die EU
hat am Montag weitere Sanktionen
verhängt gegen 20 führende Vertreter des
Regimes und gegen den iranischen Sender
erib das ist gut reicht aber nicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
denn Druck auf das iranische Regime zu
erhöhen ist richtig aber in ihrem Antrag
fordern sie überwiegend das was wir als
Koalition bereits im November in unserem
Antrag vorgelegt haben und was gerade
Beschlusslage ist dem hätten Sie hier
gerne zustimmen können eine ihrer
Forderungen ist die revolutions gerade
als terroristische Organisation
einzustufen einzustufen ja das fordern
wir Freie Demokraten auch aber bereits
im April 2021 haben die USA die gesamte
iranische Revolution wir als
terroristischer Organisation eingestuft
einer der Gründe war dass zehn Agenten
der Revolutionsgarde an der Planung
eines Terroranschlags in Deutschland
beteiligt waren im Januar 2018 wurden
sie vom Bundeskriminalamt enttarnt ich
frage mich warum die damalige
unionsgeführte Bundesregierung daraus
nicht sofort dieser Konsequenzen gezogen
hat wie die Amerikaner
warum haben sie damals nicht gehandelt
heute kommt ihr der Forderung ziemlich
verspätet ihr Antrag ist zwar gut
gemeint beinhaltet aber wenig Neues in
diesem Sinne unterstützen wir Freie
Demokraten die Arbeit der
Bundesregierung Deutschland muss jedoch
schneller handeln damit nicht noch mehr
Gefangene hingerichtet werden ein
politischer Wandel und die lang ersehnte
Freiheit für alle im Iran müssen endlich
Wirklichkeit werden
die weitere nata alt von der FDP
maxlux von Bündnis 90 die Grünen ist der
nächste Redner in der Debatte iranische
Protestbewegung frauenorientierte
Außenpolitik ein Antrag der
unionsfraktionen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
demokratischen Fraktion seit über 90
Tagen heißt es ja im Iran jinjian Azadi
San zentici also die zunächst stand
dieser Satz für Gerechtigkeit für Master
Gina armini und dafür steht er auch noch
nach wie vor aber inzwischen haben wir
doch alle erkannt und wir müssen es
aussprechen dieser Satz steht auch für
etwas weiteres er steht für den Sturz
des iranischen Regimes Gin steht für
eine Revolution im Iran
die Bewegung im Iran sie hat eine Stärke
historischen Ausmaßes angenommen diese
Stärke hat auch das brutale Regime
erkannt und es hat sehr hart
zurückgeschlagen 90 Tage des Protestes
für die Freiheit bedeuten auch 90 Tage
der Folter der Verschleppung der
splittergeschosse bedeuten zehntausende
inhaftierte mindestens 400 Tote darunter
auch Kinder bedeuten Berichte über
Vergewaltigung im Gefängnissen
Todesurteile von Menschen deren